what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm doing a
call-in show i think um
i've never done one of these before so
it's gonna be sort of like a test for
now i guess
um
okay
i'm wait let me put it so i can see oh i
can see the comment section on the side
i think
um
okay
let's
so i can see i can see the comment
section
okay
let me know how the audio sounds on here
can i share my screens i might just
react to things until someone wants to
call in
um
also
i don't know how to fix this
i
have tried i was literally trying to
figure out the settings as to why my
camera like has this black screen around
it
and
look it i can zoom in
but not so much crop out the outside so
i don't know don't know what to tell you
but if you guys want to call in we can
talk about pretty much anything that i
have discussed on the channel
um disagreements agreements whatever
um
i'm kind of awkward so if you've been
like talking too long
i may just kick you off i'm not gonna
lie to you like
until
i figure out a better
way to do it
um
that used to happen to me when i did
instagram like lives where people would
join like some people would just keep
going
and on
and on
and on
um
but yeah let me think of what
i know the fresh and fit was like the
last live that i did we talked about
fresh and fit and was he simping or not
something um
i think my conclusion was he was simping
but i think they broke up now so
i guess not for long
let me see if i can like find a video to
react to really quick
maybe that could be like the topic
um
to be honest this is very unprofessional
of me i did not have a topic
um
i just figured if anyone has like
questions or disagreements they could
call in
but
i'm gonna find a video to react to and
then we can just
talk about that
i'm gonna be honest this is just kind of
on a whim it's more of like a test to
see if i was to do a show like how i
would run one of these
so it's really just a test
um
[Music]
oh let's react to the abba and preach
video actually i watched the other day
okay
i love abba and preach
um
you want to talk about fresh simping
we can i talked about that the other day
but yeah we could start with that just
because that's like hot right now
i give the people what they want
okay let me share my screen
okay
oh wait what am i doing
um
okay
hmm
laughs
there's no volume
stop
for real
oh my god hold up
that is so sad
um audio
speaker
um
it says i can hear it
okay tell me now if you can hear this
did you guys hear that
no
darn
um
okay let's see
you can try this one and see if that
helps
on the video you react yeah that's what
i figured um
no
okay that works so
that's so odd that it doesn't
green screen audio general maybe
okay well i guess
that won't work for now
okay well i guess i'll give my thoughts
on the fresh and fit situation
um
okay so
do i think fresh was something
yeah a little bit
i mean do i think it's like this huge
deal that everybody's making it out to
be
no
not really [ __ ]
i should check out oh you know what i
could do i could play fresh and fit's
last video on my phone
i'm not saying this is like a great
option but
it's not working right now
addressing simp rumors oh
when can i hear this oh my god
oh there we go
oh my god this is a three hour this is a
three hour video
do you know where on this let's see if
there's like a time stamps okay
myron explains why fresh and fit is the
best
podcast
um
um
myron adjust is the ops i'm guessing
this is it
uh for me guys i have a goal that i'm
gonna that i want to hit uh real estate
wise before i um before i start really
like purchasing exotic cars like that
but when i do it's going to be a
lamborghini avenator and that will be
the only nice thing i own right there
because i've always wanted lamborghini
since i was a child but after that i'm
going to continue to wear these dirty
sweatpants and sweaters uh ancient fit
stay over there [ __ ] the haters yeah bro
hey listen man i'm not even mad at it
bro it is what it is like it keeps us
relevant you know it tells me like this
is what i've come to realize which is
why i'm not even mad about it anymore
we go viral this is let me tell you on
the equation of what happens
someone takes a clip of me either
kicking a chick out or making a point or
whatever something viral that we do on
the show right something
we trend on tick tock and then we turn
on instagram a million people tagged me
and world stars right and then world
star follows too as soon as that happens
someone puts a video out on us making
making some kind of accusation or
clowning us or whatever so i'm just like
all right bro like you know fool me once
shame on me fool me twice it's on me
like my process it's a part of the
process guys and i'm kind of just
getting comfortable with the fact that
like as we see more eyeballs see us more
people are going to try to have
something negative to say but you know
what
it's probably just because more people
see your videos
so
they're more likely to comment on it
you know i don't really care because i
look at it like all right for every
1 000 people that might make jokes and
talk [ __ ] and say there were frauds five
people might say yo you saved my life
that's worth it that's worth it and i
don't care if it's one making videos
with all the facts bro yeah it's funny
so so that that's what i'm just coming
to realize bro is that yo y'all gotta
understand that like we like i'd like to
say i watched every single
every single clip in my live stream last
night i don't know at least once every
month or two months
a video comes out that's vital and it's
funny too because it'll be like months
old
someone will discover shared on twitter
and then it goes nuts and then bang next
thing i know people are making videos on
us i'm like what the hell are we doing
do nothing that hot recently and then i
look like oh this video is from months
ago you know what i'm saying but it is
what it is now i'm just used to it yeah
once we give you all value you guys
should take it and learn from it that's
all that matters bro so for the most
part yeah
bro uh yo kevin durant reacted to our
video guys that was dope like kevin
durant and timbaland like bro
actually i won't say who was someone
behind the scenes saw that clip and then
come on show december and they are huge
like they're they're they're they're
huge you tell me about this on the phone
telling us
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah and also just y'all know
him and academics were literally just
talking right before the show bro that's
why i'm late these guys are like it's my
homework
y'all need to chill man
these guys talk to each other every
person that call me
oh man yeah oh oh oh
but yeah no they talk every day bro yeah
i walk in and they're just talking this
is what it is but yeah
[Music]
real quick and then well you can't do it
with a little michael sonny
is that it
um
is that it i'm like looking through this
i should be able to know i'll speak
fresh how how can i tell you one two is
it bad guys one two one two a little
better one two one two can you guys hear
it
one two one two all right it's a little
better now yeah it's okay cool they got
it all right cool that's good enough
thanks bro all right so we'll put this
profession man get into the topic yeah
no well let's make uh yeah trey's not
here guys so i'm the audio engineer as
well
the mediocre audio engineer also i want
to let you all know this too um last
night right so
we were uh last night i stayed up really
late bro i didn't sleep until like like
8 a.m yeah you i was i was redoing the
entire studio we got a new computer for
some of you guys that are wondering and
uh we got a new board as well and
anytime you get a new computer with a
new board uh you gotta recalibrate
everything so uh i pretty much did it
myself you know shout out to drake
because trey set it up for me there you
go and then yeah it's yeah that new
board right there and then we got a new
computer you guys can see a little bit
of it at chris's feet right there the
rainbow right there there you go that's
the new computer that we got guys so and
sullivan needed guys like like you back
in 2012 i appreciate the free game we
got y'all bro because here's the other
thing too that no one's gonna tell y'all
there's no one else bro that's in the
game like we are as far as like you know
what i'm saying on videos
that's like and because you guys got to
remember like a lot of guys that like
give advice on girls or whatever they're
like in in third world countries you
know what i'm saying they're telling you
how to get chicks in like you know in
other countries that aren't necessarily
infected with uh feminism and western
culture like we're here not only in the
united states but we're here in the
hardest city to pull girls piano carol
no one says miami is by far the hardest
city to pull girls because out here it's
extremely competitive yeah and we're on
demonstration girls are literally
looking for the next come up every
single day so like in this environment
bro like it's tough we've told y'all
like like we've dealt with girls that
were like oh yeah we got invited to this
party by
xyz celeb future you know what i'm
saying like future drinker here every
weekend almost swell he lives here he's
there
like yo like
oh my god
i like don't even is that it all they
talk about with
i think that's it
oh my gosh they're gonna have jordan
peterson on that would be super
interesting actually i would watch that
kevin
um
a married man wants a rotation yeah he's
looking guys yo when when we do these
phone call shows guys it's literally
like like 100 plus numbers in there so
he's got to sift through and make sure
he gets the right one all right ready uh
zero three three one yep
eight zero three three one uh you are on
the fresh and fit podcast welcome what's
up caller
hey
it's great to hear you guys i mean long
time listener first time caller i'm like
this i got a problem go ahead go ahead
let's do it
all right
i am
i am a
uh
four-year veteran of the marine corps
i am different i am with my wife for
i've been with my wife for decades i
[ __ ]
i love my wife
how do i tell her that [ __ ]
sometimes i just i gotta i gotta do what
i gotta do you know what i'm saying
oh my god so he wants to transition into
like you're gonna beat that [ __ ] yeah
you wanna you wanna
yeah um
here's the thing bro it's been tough bro
cause you've already been with her do
y'all have kids together
oh no okay but we're working on it okay
now she ain't listening to his phone
call right
okay good good good so
realistically speaking i don't want you
to answer this
all i'm gonna say is this
you need to be prepared for the worst
yeah okay so if i were in your shoes
what i would do is i'll consult with a
family lawyer
see hypothetically i know your
relationship is strong but like i will
hypothetically i will see
what um
what remedies are afforded to you if you
guys were to hypothetically divorce how
much money she going to get is she going
to [ __ ] you whatever it may be
and once you get in she only build my
business
okay so she could probably [ __ ] you up
so uh
so and the reason why i say that bro is
because you got to be prepared
for the worst sometimes and and the
thing is is that if if you drop this
bomb on her yo i want to start seeing
other girls you don't know how she's
going to react necessarily
and she might say cool let's do it or
she might get mad and use it and and and
help it makes her build resentment
against you and then that can be like
how do i the stimuli for a divorce which
obviously we don't want to divorce in
your case because she's helped you build
uh
your wealth so i mean she's that queen
she's that queen so so it's it's risky
bro because
you've been with her for 10 years you've
been faithful you want to play now
she might not be okay with that and the
thing is is that if she's not okay with
it and she decides to leave bro that's
every girl's like oh my gosh that's
every girl's worst fear
is
the stream i'm gonna remove this sorry
um it's literally like
giving up your youth and then the guy
like you get old and he trades you in
for a younger model or a rotation
she can [ __ ] you up in the process just
out of spite
so i would say this
go talk to a lawyer a family attorney in
your area okay
after you talk to him see how you need
to look at every single angle of how she
could destroy you if she wanted to and
then you need to once you know the the
facts
right then you can make an educated
decision yeah but you need to see the
worst potential of what can happen first
and see if it's even worth it to get a
new box does that make sense
right no
interesting oh we have someone that
called in let's see
hi
what's going on pearl how you feeling
i'm good how are you
doing great doing great what you think
what you think about that uh
new fresh situation
ever since i noticed like
maybe like i think it was the next
podcast afterwards like fresh is energy
change like he's a lot more stern like
my renown like his like like his face
and everything about him is different on
the podcast
um
well i've said for a long time i don't
think they really get girls like that um
like i don't think a thousand play count
doesn't really seem unbelievable to me
um
i mean i think he liked the girl i think
he was like capping a little bit i think
he liked her
um
do i mean i don't think it's that big of
a deal he did cut her off to be honest
which is like what they would say to do
right
yeah i cuz yeah when um
in terms of them getting girls uh
i could see i could see them getting a
lot of girls now now i can't speak for
myron you know because you know i can't
speak for myron
but in terms of fresh like i've seen
that video where
grant carr he was um trying out to be on
grant cardone sales team
and just listen to the way fresh talks
the way fresh looks it ain't no i don't
know where he i don't care where he was
in the world ain't no way in the world
fresh than had a thousand lake count i
could see him getting a lot of girls now
that he has
yeah
i could see that very easily now but not
a thousand now and definitely not a
thousand then like uh
now my
i can't i don't think he got that high
of a count but i could see him getting a
lot of girls even without them even
without the money in fame
well i feel like myron's so
driven
that like if he wanted to we'd figure
out a way to do it
yeah actually i met the girl when i was
on their podcast i met the girl that he
was like sort of dating or whatever
um
and to be she was like okay looking but
she wasn't like super hot to be honest
yeah so when you went on i want to talk
about your experience on that because
you were saying like
you and monye were saying that um
like the way that they talk to females
and the way they talk to men was like
different like what was the difference
there
oh well it was just the the main
difference we were talking about was
like how they acted when he was there
and when he left
like we just thought it was i just
thought it was weird that like
when he arrived and like they had every
opportunity to kick him out they like
wouldn't
and then you're gonna scream at me after
he leaves that's like the main thing i
was talking about um
i can't it was a couple months ago so i
can't remember it super clearly now i
think one yay said something about
the oh oh sorry i had to think about it
um
no it was the way they talk to girls is
just like
i don't know they kind of expect you to
be more like feminine and traditional
which i think is like what they preach
and fine but i feel like they don't
really respect your arguments as much
um when you talk
oh so like with dudes they'll be like
hey what's up man you know how you
feeling yeah
but when it was a female they'd be like
yeah i'm go sit over there no don't do
that move over here like that
yeah i mean i think that it was more
just like
like they take all the girls phones and
i get it it's because they have like
like thoughts on the show a lot to be
honest that are probably always on their
phone but i just can't imagine they do
that with their mail guests like i
highly doubt it
and but the main my main issue was that
they were they decided to yell at me
after one yay left that was my main
issue with them
well like they like they legit yelled
like voice loud yelled
yeah no it wasn't both of them like i
don't have a i didn't really have a
problem with fresh to be honest it was
my ren
um no it was like
like because
sorry it was kind of a while ago now
that i think about it but
when i got there myron
um or chris that's the third guy's name
chris right the guy behind the scenes
so when i got there chris um
like i didn't
tell chris that one yay was coming so in
the lobby he was kind of weird about it
but if they just asked him to leave it
would have been fine like i didn't care
um because one you didn't even really
want to stay like he just came to
support me like he didn't even really
want to be there to be honest it was
kind of late um we just like had just
gone on a date so we just like went
there after
um
and so then when
we got up
myron was like
super
like he was super friendly to one yeah
and he'd like talk to him and then
um then one yay left and he was like i
don't just like super cold to me the
whole time like i felt so awkward like
when i was on the live like the second
time
and then like after it ended i like went
up to him and i'm like hey like sorry if
it was
like weird that one yay was there i
didn't mean to like step in any toes and
he just started like
he was just like don't ever [ __ ] do
that again
i was like jesus christ chill man
um
like you you guys let him up
like i yeah and the crazy thing is
before he even went up i asked chris
like oh if he can leave if you want like
are you sure
and he said yeah so why are you gonna
let me let him up if like your boss has
a problem with it that's not my fault
yeah yeah that was wild cause it was it
was funny the second time i seen you go
on that show the first time was cool but
the second time like before you even
talked about your experience like i
could tell like it was something
different i didn't know what it was yeah
no it was so awkward i think someone
else is on here i'm gonna add them
hi
hey i'm just uh it's it's all cool i
just didn't want to interrupt or
anything so
now you're good anything to conversation
we just here listening and just talking
about different experiences and ideas
yeah i also jump in one thing i also
find kind of interesting about uh
as fresh and vet
is uh one it's like the
impossible or impractical body count i
think it's like
like in a
thousand it goes up practically i feel
like every second
but it's like if you think about it okay
so these guys are probably what been
living this up a lifestyle for
maybe
two to three years
so that's what roughly like a thousand
uh thousand days if it's three years
so a new woman
every day
how can you get anything done with
anything else with your life with that
type of lifestyle
it's like
well i don't understand i'm like isn't
that
unsafe like what kind of stds you guys
got
like
like you're having even if you use
condom like that doesn't stop hpv
and like like have different stis
yeah that was it and and
oh my god like a different girl every
night it it just doesn't sound practical
and it's like one thing that um
red pill gurus i guess you could say
suggests is like uh you know focus on
your purpose and it's like and i get
that because that's what i've been doing
i'm still in school um about to go back
to
an uga student about to go back
to athens tomorrow and keep studying got
finals coming up but it's like once i
start studying or just go back to work
and work a little bit on the side as a
stage hand it's like i don't have time
to really listen to y'all so it's like
[Music]
i don't know it's like i feel like a lot
of devices like pretty conflicting in a
lot of ways
so
i don't know if anyone else has noticed
like which advice i don't i haven't
watched their show really since i've
been on and since i reacted to it last
time
um so what advice are you talking about
that's conflicting
i just i think it's like
uh mostly like
focus on a purpose thing is and i i mean
i get it they have to say often it's
like new viewers and stuff but it's like
well i could do that or i could be up at
like
what i usually start streaming what like
one in the morning um east coast it's
like well you know i could work and
study and hopefully get a job when i
graduate or i could like listen to you
guys so it's like uh
and i also one reason why i don't really
like the kind of the soul advice that
people give like uh you're not just
focusing yourself i think it's it's
making people really like self-absorbed
recently mm-hmm it's like people are so
focused on like self-improvement that
like if you're not so-called like
equally as like i think it's called yoga
stem they like think you're like a worse
person and it's like no it's just not
that deep
someone said sleep oh actually they can
they have very i'm having donovan sharp
on my um
show on thursday and i actually
wanted
to have them on to talk about the
conflicting advice they give to women
um because you always hear so often in
the mana sphere like
like obviously body count's important
you want to grow with a low body count
that's fine but they also say like don't
if a girl doesn't sleep with you on a
third date
like
not to deal with her and i'm like i
think you're gonna have a hard time with
both because when i think of three dates
that's like not that much time with
someone like if i just met you off an
app or like met you in person
that's like
what one two three four like 12 hours
maybe total you've talked about yeah
like that's really not that much time
and it just like really depends on the
type of like life you want to win if you
just want to live on like the you know
new woman every day sort of like protect
sexual about your life that's
i guess completely fine at least in a
short term before
you highlight the chance of catching
something
but it's like i don't know if you want a
so-called like another term that's
thrown away like a high quality woman
like third date is
more often that's gonna be way too soon
so it's like
yeah
um i mean i think like you're right for
the bachelor lifestyle if they're like
trying to get um
like a bunch of different girls or
whatever i think that's
like that probably does make sense to
get rid of the girl after the third date
but
if you're looking if you're looking for
a wife i'm not
i just say like three dates that's
really not that much time
um
i mean unless you like knew them before
maybe i guess but like
yeah even though even
like that's really only like how long
how long do dates go like when i have a
because i'm thinking like with someone i
don't know that's gonna be like four
hours at most would you say oh well whoa
four hours at most i'm saying
like if you did like if you did like
dinner and like
um someone else is here
yeah that's fine i don't mean a monopoly
so it's
[Music]
hi parole can you hear me yeah i can
hear you hey how's it going
i'm good how are you i'm good
how's england
good i love it here
so um
i don't know how old
uh both of you are
because the guy was just talking about
for three days isn't enough
when you're older
you don't have a lot well you're too too
professional and you're trying to find
the time
like the older you get the faster you
you have to show intent
and when you're the man and you're
paying for the dates and quoting a woman
the most the fast way that she can show
interest while you're showing and i
can't hear that guy for dates it's for
her it's for her to have sex with you
so and also as as people get older men
and women generally know what they want
faster so
how old are you
you're 40 are you married
i was married
okay so i was just curious if you're
okay i was just curious if you were
still like in the dating game if that's
what you're speaking from every woman
makes sense i've had sex with on the
first date including
including my ex-wife
because men get to know
women
first
how to have
to have sex with them
you a man will not get to know a woman
in a relationship way until he's had sex
with her
i'm sorry
yeah you can roll your eyes off i could
say something i could say something to
that
like it's interesting because my like i
didn't have sex with my last boyfriend
or my boyfriend now tell like we were
dating
like
if it looks like i'm rolling my eyes
sorry i'm just trying to think and like
however
how long are we dating for is that what
you said
um
let's see i met him
first week of december we started dating
two weeks later and then we like we
didn't have sex for like a month until
after that but that's like a month
like
yes
when you're when you're a professional
and you're doing online dating you can
talk for weeks before you meet in person
and then
like
if you're if you're a professional
i'm i'm a well it was nice because we
were youtubers so we like literally like
just like
yeah and
you have a life
maybe you meet like one date and then
two weeks later you go on another date
or like
five or six or seven eight days go by so
like
three days can be a month or two i
understand what i'm saying
so yeah but to me it's like it's like
the time you spend with them though like
that's like
like on my end it's like even if there's
been a couple dates that went by like i
didn't spend it with you
you know
no i mean
like on average when i'm when i'm online
dating
it
there's usually at least a week or two
between dates between dates okay and
that's normally if we're talking like a
nine to five person that has a life and
activities that's how long it goes so
when we're talking three days i think as
you're talking about
in the context of monday tuesday
wednesday no it's like yeah we have to
find time to see each other on saturday
and then like i might not see you again
one of the reasons why people online
date
is one
if a woman has a a dating profile it
means i'm available
because we can't approach women in
public anymore or at work yeah
that is very true are available so i can
approach you number one number two
i don't have time to troll bars and go
to places and look for tail and a lot of
professional women are the same way too
they have lives and careers so they
can't just go to a bar
and close out at two o'clock
that is fine
so do you do you care about a girl's
body count does that not matter to you i
i don't care about a girl's body count
i don't date single mothers and
and and and i don't date big women
and the reason why why i don't date
large women it isn't it isn't because of
the physical part that's the second to
it
i've never been heavy but i've been
uncomfortable
with the body i was in enough where i
was absolutely miserable
and i don't date
larger women because
the the mental conversations
that they're having with themselves
and the insecurities
that they have
their their partner is going to have to
pay for it there's no reason why you
should ever ask me
do i look big in this dress i'm not
standing for that
so
people think that i don't
yeah they're not physically attractive
big people particularly the bigger women
you can't say anything mean
to large women because it reminds them
of the conversations that they have with
themselves late at night when they're
looking up at the ceiling in bed or
looking at themselves in the mirror
and
you're gonna have to pay for that it's
the same thing as like a woman
dating a broke guy
lot of times a broke guy is going to
make his issues with her making more
money than him her problem
oh i had a friend like that her
boyfriend would always like mention how
she made more money than him yeah like
it wasn't even like she didn't even care
but it was like he kept bringing it up
yeah
i i just wanted to say pearl like one of
the biggest things with your channel
is um
first off it's great to talk to you
um
is
there's a disc
and i think you've seen a taste of it
because you you know donovan sharp or
you've been on like fresh and fit but
like
you have no idea
like so there's the manosphere and then
there's the the black
okay and
black men we have a whole different
a whole different set of problems
separate from any other group of men
because our
our culture is a matriarchy
okay okay
are you rolling your eyes again or is it
just the thing
no
oh sorry yeah i'm just
wait
i wasn't rolling my eyes no no not you
i'm talking the other guy oh okay no
sorry i'm just uh if i if i seem a bit
off i'm just i'm just taking down notes
and i often just like look up to see
i know i i agree for the most part so
that's we're all completely good so
sorry for being disrespectful
you know i i've seen you talk to richard
cooper
and all these different guys
but
you
you're on the outside looking in
like i think i can see you kind of
interconnected with the regular
manosphere where you're kind of so
disconnected from the black manosphere
and the experience of black men when it
comes to like black women in general
and i'm hoping that somehow you can get
a better understanding of that because
i've been on this planet for for 40
years
i have a graduate degree i'm a i'm a
professional you know you know i'm i'm
well into the middle
six figures and
i um
i hear like people like kevin samuels
they speak he speaks for
you know the
the the black men like me who
um
the earlier part of my life you know
because i was educated i spoke a certain
way like i couldn't it wasn't until i
was 35 that i was able to regularly date
african-american women
because i'm single i don't have any kids
you know i
i broke the six figure barrier and i'm
one of those guys where now that i'm 40
i can take my pick and if you would have
told me
when i was 25 that i have the options i
have now all i have to do is stay
childless
get get a
graduate degree and get some money and
so
it's just i'm hoping that you can get a
better understanding as to where black
men come from because in my opinion you
can't group black men and black men as a
whole into the patriarchy because we
don't have anything
we're the least linked to the least
educated the least
every measure of benefit of the
patriarchy black men in general we don't
benefit from we just don't
yeah we suffer in silence our you know
like
i when i say the majority i say 51
50 the majority of our women like i
remember
like
the majority of our women are not on our
side and we have to make it out here by
ourselves
so what do you
like i see your content and i i see you
working to be interconnected with the
regular manosphere when i see you
commenting on stuff like kevin samuels
and and you know
and
and you know kind of the black
manosphere it's just i just wish that
there's a way that you could be more
cognizant of the struggles that
that
it's like
one of the biggest
disconnects is
black women
one of the normal expectations of dating
a black woman is you know the their list
of regulars include
respect me as a boss
you know uh you know have a job be six
foot tall and accept my children
no other wow no other group of men is
expected to accept another man's
children
you should accept my children
and you're not a real man no other group
of men has to suffer from their will
i don't understand how these girls get
pregnant so much to be honest you can
get like an iud and be good
like
like it's not you get an iud once you're
good like you know how hard it is to get
pregnant with an iud it's like yeah but
nine point
it's like rare but they keep it a stack
um
and
uh
uh
in the communities i guess you could say
that it often happens around i mean a
lot of these chicks are in um what's uh
what's it called medic medicaid and i'm
not i'm not sure if that covers an idea
yeah but there's still like there's
still
condoms you can track yourself
here's the thing
it it it starts way before that
no one can tell these women anything it
starts with that
mm-hmm
do you think that's because um a lack of
like like
you said it's a matriarchy so would you
say it's like a lack of like fathers in
the home or like father is that what
you're saying it is
this is just my honest belief uh well
i think
that's it but it's just
um
i'm just gonna use this as an example
what's your name
mac
yeah and schmuck um
you're african-american right
yeah i i know i look crazy but i'm just
i'm home from school and
oh yeah my fifth year hopefully lost so
do you have a job
oh yeah i work as a stagehand right now
so make around 16 hour minimum if this
has been your experience
but in my life in a professional and
academic setting
my worst enemy isn't a white person it's
usually it's usually another black
person
yeah that's true
that's true
because they're loud they're obnoxious
and no one can tell them anything
and this is from like
when they're younger it's like people
let black women act a certain way
and so
yeah i have my
own uh specific experience with kind of
that whole deal um
it's uh pretty hard kind of being like
uh and sorry like my microphone's not
that good i'm on my laptop so
if i was uh back in my apartment for
school
loud and clear but um
yeah so kind of
one issue that i kind of
ran into um and i still run into a lot
and i guess in our community and it's
not just like black men or black women
but just like the whole afrom
african-american community i guess you
could say it's like groupthink it's like
you know well i can understand like why
you know large part of us think certain
ways you know shared experiences and all
but it's like when you kind of not
necessarily telling other people like oh
you're wrong and stupid but if you have
like a slightly different take slightly
different opinion slightly different
lifestyle then people start looking at
you
and you know that's when you get start
getting called to things like you know
your uncle um what's it uncle tom that
sort of stuff and
yeah um has that been your experience
yeah and
kind of i actually have a very poignant
experience um
i remember like and
this is like so recent so like college
nowadays and it's having uh
sorry man
i'm sorry i can see it no it's yeah my
my this i'm on a laptop this microphone
that's not good so
um yeah so we well
sorry but not to say you're old but we
all have like smartphones now one app
that's really popular um on college
campuses nowadays it's called group me
and so
some people were talking about like oh
you know rent's too high in athens and i
was saying like uh yeah it kind of sucks
i should build more houses and then it
was like
not to turn this political but like
there are some uh uh some
i get some people in like the black
student union who are like communists
and stuff and you know i i read up all
that stuff you know i and i and i was
and i kept exploring i thought about a
little bit and i decided it wasn't for
me and i kind of gave a different
opinion i said like they just need to
build more houses supply and demand
then like i got called all sorts of
things that to be honest i don't want to
repeat uh
what for me is like
letting yourself get
what's right
okay usually um could you please wait
till he's done talking oh i know i added
you to the stream but like typically
it's like kind of rude to interrupt
oh yeah i i i didn't even hear the buddy
but um uh
yeah i i can say it's definitely been a
struggle um just kind of being like a
black professional professional and i've
only really at the foot of that um i
still have
this semester and the next one to finish
before anyone can say that i'm uh
what's it like i'm studying mechanical
engineering so what's it like a
engineering and training
i can't even call myself an engineer
until i
work a little bit so
yeah
well just make it till you're 35 man the
the whole world opens up to you
and
so when they say be because i heard you
earlier talk about empowerment and
people are like they're so busy
empowering
themselves but you have to understand
black men
we're just now getting into a culture
where it's okay for black men to talk
about empowering ourselves because i was
there in the 90s with all this
misandrious
garbage okay don't ever talk about
empowerment being bad when we're
when we're when we're a group of men
we're only in the last 10 years has it
been okay for us to even talk about
empowering ourselves
i'm telling you wayne exhale the color
purple all this missandra's garbage
we're finally getting out of that so and
i get that and um
everybody else you can say that too but
as black men i didn't start hearing
messages outside my family about black
men empowerment until
until the last five to ten years and
that's it
yeah i i get that and i guess a quick
question
you said you're around 40 years old so
that means so that means you would have
been born what and
okay so
um
my parents i guess my father yeah so he
was born in 95 so he kind of grew up
during you know
uh
80s and a lot of that stuff and
when did the
not the
i can't remember which it's a
sorry it's like so the color purple
color when did that come out it was like
1984 don't quote me on that it was in
the early 80s
it used to be one of my favorite movies
up until i got this yeah okay
i was 32 and i saw how much you know
like i i started putting together that
i've never i always hear about that
movie i've never heard of it i've never
watched it it was one of my favorite
movies up until like i was 32 and i'm
like what the heck is like what anyway
go ahead matt
yeah so i mean i've never seen it it's
kind of not in my generation but i know
generally just from i guess
being a student and studying history
i know i've been from listening from
kevin he talks about it quite a bit um
so i mean just to keep it a stack before
uh i guess
any of us were around except for i asked
the other um
other guy
i mean there was like the
nation of islam and a lot of stuff like
that and
and and
you know i don't want to go like super
political but you know i mean a lot of
that was you know like you know um
empowerment of the male uh black men and
i'm not saying it's like inherently bad
i'm just saying that it sometimes just
go off the rails when you're just kind
of getting like a little bit of an echo
chamber because
you know
the nature of islam started off as like
okay you know we want to conduct
ourselves in certain manner and you know
honestly honestly we'll take us
seriously but then that's when you start
islam is such a small percentage of
african americans that like i mean they
made an impact but it was never a large
percent of us it was never more than
like five oh yeah i don't know
it's kind of it's like you can use it as
an example but like it wasn't a big
behavioral shift and honestly it wasn't
even even enough
it wasn't around long enough to really
change the culture because you know
while the nation of islam was popular
there was the monahan report
in monahan scissors you know the nation
the victim was around you know
african-american male uh employment rose
but then black female welfare uh
enrollment rose up too so
i i mean you can talk about it all you
want
it wasn't really a cultural
i mean i i get that
it wasn't it wasn't large but i kind of
brought them up because you know i mean
i believe
just the facts that i mean
after malcolm x said like hey you know
i'm kind of not with y'all anymore and
he started disagreeing with them a
little bit i mean he just assassinated
him so that's like one thing that i'm
starting to see a little bit and uh i
guess you could call it
again i'm so kind of tuned out in
general just from
personal life a little bit it's that
like kind of like you know a lot of
things that i see like in a lot of these
communities online it's like oh if you
disagree with someone you're not just
like raising a point it's all now all of
a sudden you're what's it your cuck your
beta your your your blue pill or your
thing about it
and it's like like what
like i'm just
here and i'm not saying you're doing
that i'm just saying that's what
happened this whole male space is new
empowerment once again like i i hate
like i don't want to hold i'm staying
home last time the fact that you said so
many people are so focused on
empowerment that it kind of becomes
selfish this space is new
i've been around 40 years i grew up in
washington state one of the most liberal
upper crust areas and and i didn't hear
any of this growing up
especially like white women like like
it's funny because being being a black
man is the most
anti
anti-feminist art like you're like a
walking talking anti-feminist argument
because there's no white woman that
that has a worse experience than a black
man in this country i'm sorry
in any way shape or form
i don't i've never met a white woman
that would want to trade places with me
as a black man
so
so most of most of the stereotypical
feminist arguments i just bring up my
experience
would you want to be me
no
so all i'm saying is well i think that
women in general don't understand how
privileged we are especially when we're
young
um like i remember my first my first um
my first job i had was a sales job i
worked in sales for two years
um and i was the only girl in the office
and i remember like
my one of my co-workers said something
to me like that all the like upper
management would always like help me
like with whatever i asked like if i
ever wanted one-on-one time with like
like my manager's manager my manager's
manager's manager like they would always
like just do it and like at the drop of
a hat be ready and like they said
something to me like oh it's because
you're a girl and i was like what no
like it's because i'm so nice and like
friendly and whatever
um
that's made pro you're talking about
handy handy i think it wasn't short
you're talking about handing your rights
back
i was just kidding i didn't actually
want to do that and i guess i mean you
just
as opportunity to ask you one of the
things that i don't understand and mac
how old are you buddy
i'm uh 22. so
oh you're a young buck
yeah young buck
yeah i'm gonna ask
about this too
in my experience
because
when i was young my i
my dad
he's a
a physician and my dad told me that you
and your brother are gonna have to play
what he i'm using my dad's term the
man's game the man's game is you go into
the work you get a job where you're 16
and you're going to work until you're
dead and the most aspect is what you're
going to get is to put yourself in a
position
to support a wife and children the best
way possible
right and so
in my experience
with this female female empowerment
feminism thing a lot of women think that
they want to play the man's game as my
dad put it get to 30 to 33 years old and
realize if i'm not careful i'm going to
be doing this the rest of my life this
sucks
they want to find a way out
but the problem is anything that you're
good at you have to practice that even
relationships but that's why i don't
mind if a woman's divorced it shows that
she's been with the man she knows how to
have relationship skills and whatever
but i've met women as a professional
that are 35 years old have never had a
serious relationship one thing that i
don't understand and maybe pearl you can
if you can help me out with this is
why are so many women that want to rush
out there and fight in the world of men
um fight with the sharks when if you're
fit
feminine and friendly enough you don't
have to fight the world because you can
find a man who just gave it to you
well see it's interesting because
i i feel like like white culture is
really different than like black culture
um so like i've seen like a lot of i
have a lot of black girls say like they
want a guy to like take care of them and
like whatever but like
i don't know in in i would say like
upper upper middle class like white
cultures like where i grew up like
suburbs like it was never expected for a
guy to like pay for everything but like
dates you know what i mean like i've
never had a girl that like like her
boyfriend pays all the rent
um so i don't i don't know just like
growing up like
like i'm just really driven so i never
even thought about it to have like a guy
take care of me like i always just
wanted to work
which i wanted to add something to that
too i wanted to add something because i
have a lot of black friends too and a
lot of black guys they want to say
they're willing to date outside of the
race because the woman is friendlier
outside of the race as opposed to the
woman that's black who's more combative
who likes to
maybe
uh equate massive energy that they have
to the man
so they have problems like that
so i just wanted that question because
there's black men here in this chat
and uh some of my best friends one of my
first best friends was a black person
and i remember the reality is that me as
latino and him as a black person and we
understood our cultures and uh honestly
the differences i understood what we've
gone through as opposed to a white
person but it's interesting how we're
willing to decide date outside of our
race yet the black woman isn't that's
what's very interesting no no okay okay
let me shed some light on that my friend
here's the thing
okay
30 of black men with a bachelor's degree
or higher
have married out i grew up in washington
state where only like two percent of the
population is black so like i needed a
lot of white girls growing up right
and i can tell you what
black women think that
see dating and pearl can
talk about this too dating a person of a
different race takes work
and if you're willing to do the work it
can work out but it takes work because
you have different experience and here's
the thing about it
the white person has to choose to take
on the experience of dating someone
outside the race because white people
are seen as quote unquote normal and in
the back of your mind
whether you're a black man or a black
woman you have to get comfortable with
them having that option of saying they
can leave whenever they want and go back
to their white life and not have to deal
with this i'm not saying that the white
person would but they have that option
because
being white is being seen
seen as quote unquote normal
oh black people but i heard the men at
risk
men are more likely to take risks
black women just think that the black
men
did it outside the race is just easy
black men we know about the risks we
know how tough it is
we're more willing to do it kevin
samuels said the best black women think
that men are just free
so black women
they know for a fact that the garbage
that they put black men through white
men aren't going to deal with it they're
just not
yeah that's true
and that's the whole point that i was
trying to make
men of other races expect women to get
on their program and a lot of black
women don't want to get on a man's
program period
so it's not like they don't a lot of
black women
for various reasons can't because they
don't want to do the work necessary or
they don't want to take the risk i don't
want to be a white guy's chocolate
fantasy that
you know
what if he fetishizes me as a black man
who's internationally dated i'm just
i got to the point where i can tell if a
woman was fetishizing me or not
you know what i'm saying you have to
take me
can you explain what i don't understand
what fetishizing is to be honest because
i'm like like a lot of times like people
will say that and i'm just like okay so
they're attractive so uh
i'll keep you short and quick because i
like hearing your guys's stories
um so me as a latino there was like
these rich white older ladies when my
father was working for uh his company uh
he owned a company of construction
landscaping and so there's that
stereotype of the latino man who's
cutting the grass was cutting the trees
doing construction work
in a person's house and there were these
older rich white ladies that uh they
started telling me about these clubs and
these bars where they like to pick up on
young hung men
and i remember my father
i would do the estimates because i would
talk english my dad could probably just
talk spanish so he needed my help with
the address the estimates the numbers so
i talked to the client so there were
these women that would start finishing
fetishing uh because i worked out and i
was fit and i was an athlete and stuff
more before back in the day
um so they started you know
um
i gave them my cell phone number for
business originally but ended up
becoming personal
and they started inviting me over and
then it ended up becoming these
fantasies of like
those like kind of like porn sketches
where like oh it's the guy in the back
cleaning the pool
and then you know these fantasies where
you go into the room and like they're
wearing these sexy [ __ ] or like these
like
bdsm type stuff and that's me dominating
the woman so i had these experiences
myself a few times even though it was
kind of somewhat stereotypical but i
liked it because i was getting you know
[ __ ] and money they were paying me i
was like a sugar baby for a bit
oh man yeah
that's not what i was expecting
yeah yeah it happens it happens
i like it i love it
mine was oh man
oh my god i can't believe i'm about to
like say this my parents house but like
oh my god
all right so and like i just write a
little bit of context um i've actually
never had like a long-term relationship
before it's all been kind of casual and
i have my my own kind of regret about
that but anyway
so kind of what people mean by being
fetishized especially um you know as a
black man i'm like lights again so i
don't even get it as much but it's still
a thing
so let's say i guess we could say like
one
casual encounter i had um
she was
really
wanting to you know you know dude indeed
for i was just like and i was thinking
and i was like what uh 19th and ethics
and it was like my first time so i was
just like oh yeah sure
and then you know we do the thing to be
honest it wasn't even that good
just it was awkward it was only really
like
two dates before then
and then like after you know kind of you
know
did the deed and then she oh my god she
hits me with this one question and i'm
just like
how could you ask something like this
like did did like d d just not have like
social awareness she asked me like okay
so i'm thinking about getting like a a a
trap
trap stamp and i'm thinking and i'm
thinking like well i'm like i have no
tattoo she obviously knows that
so i'm thinking like why the [ __ ] are
you asking me and then she asked me like
okay so
how offensive do you think this would be
and that's how you know it's already
about to go [ __ ] bad yeah
and i feel like you already know what
she's about to ask but she
i have no idea so she was
saying like okay so how would she so she
starts off like okay so you know about
like the
the the 50s and the 40s and i'm thinking
like okay like it's 2018 like what the
[ __ ] are we talking about in the 50s and
she was saying like so you know how like
they had different um different water
fountains and like okay i'm from atlanta
just by the way i'm just gonna throw it
out there and i'm thinking like okay
what the [ __ ] i'm already seeing where's
this going so i'm already like mentally
preparing myself for like no she's not
about to ask this if she ask like okay
so what do you think about me getting
like a like a blacks only champ stamp
and i'm just thinking they're like you
just did not just [ __ ] ask that like
bro what happens
uh
there's a thing where is especially
amongst white women
they they they want to find an
attractive black guy because
they can say to all their friends oh my
god
you're dating a black guy and they get
this like this different kind of
attention
it's that edgy thing it's the cool thing
and the well never runs dry ever yeah
and i also think it's like what does
that mean the well never one right
attention
you get a different kind of attention
from like your
your white girlfriends and everybody
for dating a black guy it's like
everyone is curious
do the fetishizers like marry them too
or they just stay there sometimes it
depends so sometimes some of these women
end up falling for that guy sometimes
they become a sugar baby like i was for
a while
um some of these women they network you
and they plug you into other women so i
started meeting other women through the
woman i was [ __ ]
when i was a sugar baby and i they
started i want to say pass me around
they started taking me on cruises
uh started like shipping out some other
places
i started getting to work and i started
finding out people networking business
to go up in status
but these women were dang i had like a
milf cougar status a fetish for me so i
love the mills and cougars for a while i
still somewhat do but i love young women
too so don't get me wrong legal not
young like r kelly but legal
oh my god
well i
i've just heard people use that word and
like sometimes they have like like kids
with the guy and i'm like it's not
reaching like a little bit that would be
probably called like a polygamous family
if they got
if they got like children you know
no because i hear i hear fetishizing
like used a lot and i'm not saying it's
always used correctly
like the whole like squirrel
by what they're dealing with outside of
outside of the outside of the person
being black
and attractive because a lot of women
who fetishize black men
they deal with
they're willing to deal with a whole lot
of crap
yeah if they can find that pretty boy
black dude and get the attention from
digging
that kind of guy so the cheating they
can heal and all that stuff like that
you know
the kind of women
like
if you see a white woman
dealing with some black youtube driving
your car around when she's at work and
all this crazy stuff oh she's
fetishizing
when yeah
when the bad outweighs the good and
she's still in it
and you're like a white woman
you're fetishizing with the guy
and yeah because some of these women
don't think they're just attached
no no it's it's a pretty obvious towel
okay i don't know what it i just i know
a lot of girls that stay there
well the thing is the thing is so these
women are playing the fantasy of getting
the chat or tyrone and they couldn't get
the chatter tyrone and it's like that
it's like the edgy cool thing to do so
for example uh one of what one of the
men here on here one of youtube black
guys i don't i'm sorry for not saying
like that but one of you two young men
that's cool
you guys would be like a chat or tyrone
to some of these women so they'd be like
okay i got this chatter tyrone and i'm
[ __ ] him and he's [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of me and he's pleasing me and he's
cool
edgy
and
this is just interesting to me because i
always hear that word but i never really
know what it means yeah it's just
i gotta i gotta
do things uh i i see what you're saying
about what the whole kid sings and like
me and like a lot of other people i know
kevin calls it like the squirrel or no i
believe it's ocean calls it like the
whole swirl thing where like and i
believe like avon priet should be like
if y'all watch them they talk about oh
people who just want to like get into
like a different uh or um
you're saying it's usually like a broke
so a broke dude and like it's like a
white girl and she's like lending him
him her car and she's like doing all
this stuff and she just doesn't care as
an example i'm not saying that usually
there can be a bunch of reasons why the
bad is out
outweighing the good
just
i was just wondering okay
sometimes a white woman just wants some
bbc
yep that's another thing i was about to
mention real quick right um and you know
i'm not like super like you know
oh you know put your put your hand on
the bible before you know or i'm not
even
i'm a little bit religious i haven't
actually been raised in a church but uh
that's a whole another conversation but
i feel like like i feel like porn is
like ruined like a generation
no i don't know not
because they come up like some people
come up to me and like it's super
obvious to tell like they only come up
to you because they think you're packing
and it just like gets it gets old after
a while it's like no
i'm a person
why would you see that that sounds like
a personal problem
let me tell you
let me tell you let me tell you why you
you shouldn't think
that's a bad thing we don't have a lot
of positive stare like every other
racing every other group
of people have positive stereotypes
except us
so we got to take the ones that we can
get if a woman wants to sleep with you
because she thinks
does she have a big dick go for it
i mean think about the list of positive
stereotypes you have you have as a black
man
here's the thing i mean usually it's
like what like basketball that since i i
can't even do so dude i'm six foot three
i don't play basketball either but what
i'm saying is is post me faster just
count
what can work for you in a positive way
because we don't have much
we really don't
uh i guess just
dude i'm like 5 10 5 11 latino
what do you got again i guess it's
positive if you're trying to like i
guess you know like trying to keep a
rotation but it's like no i'm trying to
like settle down because i've like
flipped that kind of see
that's the thing like like
once you get a serious
relationship like you're going to have a
different mindset
like because because i didn't have my
first serious girlfriend until i was 20.
and then we dated from earlier to me
up until up until i was 25. was that was
that your wife or was that your no
so
she was a white girl she was three
quarters white and a quarter
native american and then we broke up
these i moved off to college my ex-wife
was um was actually west africa
that was my little band-aid because i
could not find a black woman that i
wanted to be married and i
it was hard for me to
because there's just certain things i
will not deal with so like i think i
want to marry a black woman and so i
found a cameroonian woman and we were
together for five years but then we had
long distance
we ended up breaking up
going
you were married to her or you were
together for five years
mary so the my first girlfriend i was
with for for four and a half years five
years but my wife we were together for a
year and then married for four
okay wait so um how old were you i was
30.
you were 30. so she was eight years
younger than me sir
she was
she was 27 years
so she was 23 and i was 30.
she was 23. so why'd you guys get
divorced if you don't remember so
um
we only knew each other forever for a
year and
and i got married to her
and
we ended up moving across the country
and
one thing you have to do
gentlemen is
start the relationship in a masculine
frame
because i made the mistake i didn't
start our relationship with a masculine
brain
and by the time i realized that it was
too late because once someone has
established a pattern a pattern
of behavior it's hard to get
her to stop so so me like
she wouldn't stop spending money
your money
i i let her emotionally manipulate me
every time i wanted to have a serious
conversation about money she knew
exactly what to say to kind of shame me
out of it
and that was my fault you know i i ended
up going to therapy at the divorce and
figuring out that like
all this was my fault
and so
um
she was spinning
and then she she was a college student
uh oh
university while we were obeyed at a
uh that was a party school that you
can't be in a serious relationship in
marriage
or or married and go to and be a student
at this college quick question
a bunch of money
university of washington just quick
question just curious
university of las vegas
oh hell no sin city oh hell no yeah yeah
dude nothing but porn stars fake ass
celebrities and snakes are living oh
[ __ ]
no go zones
no no it's good to smash women it's good
to smash them in there but don't the
people there are very funky and they're
i live in california so i've been to
vegas plenty of times i mean and it's
very important so i can tell you all
about it everyone's feeding me
i'm from atlanta so i get a little bit
of the fast food but go ahead i have a
question um when you
you're dating now you're 40.
so it's interesting because the
manusphere really pushes age gaps and i
really i understand like why like
obviously that benefits the guy because
she's like younger she could have kids
but like data wise um it doesn't support
that age gap like dating actually works
better like if anything the divorce rate
is like much much higher
um and so i'm curious like dating now do
you prefer dating girls that are younger
or do you prefer dating girls that are
your own age so i only date women
between 28 and 35
okay because
women my age first off oh okay so ever
since um also sorry just really quick
i'm gonna let you answer that question
really quick um mac i'm going to kick
you off because um it only lets four at
a time
and i'm gonna let someone else on the
stream and you've been here the longest
oh okay well i just
i wanted to say a few things but uh
that's fine
yeah thanks so much for coming on sorry
i just i try to keep it fair
oh by the way pearl there's a there's an
option there where you can let more
streamers so i've heard like up to eight
to ten streamers can be on the stream
yarn so if you were one of the options
you have to pay for it
yeah i get it you're on a budget in the
uk
um but you're rich but you're rich my
parents are rich i'm not rich
okay sorry would you mind responding so
you said 28 to 35 why so
so
we don't build together in the black
community we just don't
and so you you have two individuals
that are trying to come together to
become interdependent and unfortunately
because ever since i got divorced
six years ago i've been trying to
exclusively date black women because i
have a lot of black women women women
available now but the biggest problem
is is
the older first part children
the
majority of black women there are more
working black women with children than
our working black men without them
and i won't tolerate that like i do i
don't date single mothers so number one
number two the older a woman gets like
it's
usually when a woman's a professional
she she has like you meet the buzzer
beaters
who are 35
and trying to have a kid before they're
in geriatric pregnancy so they want to
you know they want to get one in
real quick
or
or or in the black community black men
are expected to accommodate the woman
and that's how they approach you dating
and it's like no so so
living between 27 and 35 they haven't
they have a different mentality than
women 35 and older they're still able to
see
you know to to
to come at a situation
with a man
you know
willing to try to get on this program or
figure the most women over 35 who are
professionals at least
are trying to fit a man into their life
like okay i think i can slide you in on
tuesdays and thursdays
or
on that so
the two
one of the questions i ask up front is
if you if you get married would you
change your last name and i'd say maybe
80 of the 35 year old
they say no
35 years or older women say no
wow
that's what they say that that's what
they say if a woman isn't is 35
when she's over 35 if she's not married
by then she's most likely not going to
get married ever they said it's a
statistic the same thing
same statistic
so
let me
so
when i go out with a woman
because i want to be married by the time
i'm 43
and i say this outright
and to the two questions i asked one if
you get married
would you change your last name and the
if the answer is no
or or hyphenating i i can't with you no
[Music]
number two if we're driving down the
road
i'm driving you're in the passenger seat
and we come up to a t intersection
and i stop and say i want to make a left
turn let's go what would you say
now the right answer would be
i trust you make a left turn let's go
but most
women over 35 they want you to pull at
this instance
they want you to pull the car over
why do you want to make that left turn
explain to me why
did you consider my feelings before you
made that turn what makes you think wait
a turn that's such a small thing but
that's the thing about that's the
problem with older women
okay
the other thing i've heard you do
a woman over 35 most of the time they
use this term partnership right and
partnership
to them means everything everything that
you do as a man is negotiable even the
static stuff
but but so
so
everything has to be negotiated of what
of what you do
with them
and i don't have time for it i want a
woman who will say you know what
i trust you i have confidence in you
let's get going because a lot of times
if we're stopping at the t intersection
we only have 20 minutes
to get somewhere you want to spend 15
minutes arguing about whether to make
to make a
a left turn or not
so
that's been my struggle
with women over 35. it's
a lot of them have to try to fit a man
in
their lives and
no man worth a day wants to be fit into
into a woman's life a lot of women who
who are 35 years
older they dismiss the journey of being
a man
they don't understand how tough it is to
be successful as a man and the way they
talk to you you're like you have no idea
how tough like how
the work i've had to do to get to this
point
and it's just and then the buzzer
beaters once again women
a lot of women over 35 they want to
slide that kid in real quick they're
like oh my god i'm in geriatric
pregnancy i gotta get a kid real quick
and you can just tell
by the way they're walking the way that
they're talking they're like i need to
get a kid real quick
[Music]
so before twenty you before 35 27 you
know 27 to 35
you can get a good
i think and do not do not go younger
than that so like a 22 year old that'd
be too young no that's too young
the youngest i dated in the last
five years was
was 26. is that because of like a lack
of mental maturity is that why uh
i'm pretty set my ways ways a lot of
things and the younger you go the more
you have to um
let me give you a basic a basic example
so
i have a 16 year old nephew and whenever
he
he's in the car
i let him play the radio
and he plays garbage and i'm like man if
you're with a woman that's too young
it's like that we're like
oh you don't get the same like pop
culture references and yeah that's
something okay
you know like like
seven eight years you know you're still
within the scene kind of
yeah well it's just interesting it's
just
interesting because the manosphere is so
much like data driven but like that's
the one piece of data they really ignore
and i'm not really against like age gap
dating like at all um like i i don't
care
but
it's just interesting because it's like
10 years or more like the the divorce
rate is like much much higher than less
than 10.
and so i was just curious like the
reasoning as to why from your
perspective because you've actually
dated or different like age ranges
yeah i just you know
i'm just hoping that you can get more
experience with the black man sphere
because
uh you know i've commented on a couple
of your live streams and stuff and you
know the only time the only time i've
gotten frustrated is
you literally can't group black men in
with any other type of group with our
women because no other group of men have
never had a chance to be in a masculine
frame until the last 10-15 years i'm
sorry we we do have
and i'm talking i'm talking in the
mainstream
we had
we had michelle obama
say that sometimes she she feels like a
single mother
when she was married to barack obama and
he was president
you got access to hell and nannies like
get out of here
the level of misandry
and
53 of us are single are single and
childless
and and all of us had to become men on
the fly like i was lucky enough to have
my parents married i grew up in a nice
neighborhood but i'm to the point where
i can tell the young black men
have fathers and the main reason why a
lot of us are single and childish is
because we didn't want to be
what our our nay nays and mamas and
grandmas talked about so we stayed
single and we stayed childless
but a lot of us want to be married a lot
of us
want to have kids but we can't it's hard
for us to find women who just cooperate
with us
and be nice to us kevin samuels had that
video where um
you know you know he ended the video and
he said i know i know more guys that say
i don't got to worry about the white man
because i got to worry about this
this person right here
she's the one that calls the police into
my house she's and that's how it is with
a lot of black men
like we don't
it's there's just straight up hostility
and black men we've accepted it for way
too long
and that's why you know like like a lot
of us black men we're like running
towards
the black ministry because our whole
lives you know you know you know
we've heard our fathers and uncles uh uh
and brothers and coaches and
no figures trashed all over
this is the first
you know i'm in this
uh
in a little bit but i've been on this
planet for 40 years and a guy like kevin
samuels he talks to me like my father
talked to me when i was younger
like he
he is reversing
it you know
and o'shea
and all them they are they are fighting
back against 40 years
of just
of just misandry
in the black community
and
and we voted with our feet by not having
children not getting married 54 of us
now that we've gotten where the majority
of us
don't have kids
and aren't married we're trying to
figure out what to do now
yeah
once again we spent most of our life
trying to not be that bogeyman
that our grandmas and aunties and
moms talked about i'm not you know let's
say you're like
a young black boy whose dad was a
quote-unquote
deadbeat and you never got your dad's
excited story 53 of them don't are
single don't have jokes
so i'm not a deadbeat i'm i'm a
professional
i have a good job i'm not a deadbeat so
now what and that's what kevin samuels
and all them are helping us figure out
what we grew up with is don't be a
statistic don't get a girl pregnant
don't be a dead because that's what
black men are i'm not going to be there
but now so so i have a question um out
of let's say 10 kids that don't have a
dad in the home what percent of those
like that are black what percent would
you say is because the mom won't let the
dad see the kids and what percent do you
say is because the dad's down in the
picture
uh
i couldn't give you that number you know
just not
oh
i was going to say it doesn't have to be
like factual it's just like from what
you've seen i grew up in like a
prominently white neighborhood oh okay
okay all of the
there were four families the four black
families in my neighborhood and all of
them were married
so
um but
i just
i've just heard it's a lot like it's a
lot more like the moms not letting the
dad like them see the kids then um well
because here's the thing about it though
we
we we use the term broken homes
right but broken means that there was a
foundation there to break
the majority of black homes never had a
foundation to be broken so you can't
even call them broken homes
like
if you like a woman keeping a man away
from seeing his kids like
they were never married they were never
married and
in almost 80 percent i don't know what
percentage i'd say over 50
of
of the children born born on a wedlock
was just sex
you know sex that a turn
into a child so you know i don't really
see
you know i i i don't know
keeping the woman away from the i mean i
couldn't comment i don't know you don't
have to answer if you don't know you
could just say you don't know oh yeah
but you know i would just say you know
you you a lot of these women
only only a small percentage of black
men are getting all these women pregnant
almost 50 percent of black women that
have more than one child
have two different baby fathers it's
just you know wait what percentage
should you say also
i didn't realize i could add more people
than for it's that i could yeah before
but anyway
i'm just saying you know
i'll wrap it up and get off you know i'm
a 40 year old man graduate degree i'm in
the six figure range and i'm trying to
date black women and everything that
kevin samuel says
well but it is true and so
so once again
just
if i could leave you with anything 53 of
black men single single single entitled
list and we got here because we heard
horror stories about
how black men are and that's why percent
of especially single
child
when you think about these men
we're trying to so you're saying
so you're saying i what i don't
understand is just like
um how different it is in the black
community because it's like a matriarchy
yeah because and because like the women
are more like combative and there's a
low level of disrespect and i would say
low-level hatred
yeah basically basically
basically from what i've seen and what
i've heard too is um
women love equality when it benefits
them but don't like it when it doesn't
benefit them and i've seen a double
standard where there's a saying oh we
got to protect our black queens the same
thing the same thing as we have got
particular
latina queens but
these women a lot of times they take
[ __ ] for granted when's the last time
these women have gone to shape a
construction worker's hand and thanked
them for building the infrastructure
when's the last time they want to go and
shake and thank a policeman because nine
times out of ten it's a male officer
coming to your house to check up on you
when's the last time you shook in the
hand and thanked me who i used to be
special forces in the marine corps and i
used to be a combat in the tanks you
watched me fury that's my job as well i
used to be in that service and barely
women even thanked me at all unless i
was in uniform if i wasn't in uniform i
don't blame them they didn't know
because i wouldn't brag about it but
they would never think that they take it
for granted like you said yourself they
take us for granted a lot of times
us men a lot of us we're the kings of
this world we're the apex predators
we're the rulers we're the kings the
presidents the dictators the generals of
the armies
the athletes who watch
it
it's interesting because it turns into
envy so quick because all of those
positions like women other than
construction and infrastructure like
women will complain that they're not in
you know what i'm saying well athletes
like yeah but this is the thing though
it's it's choice it's all choice a woman
can say yeah i want a woman a woman that
chooses to go to the military but
doesn't choose to be in combat i
understand because she cannot most of
the time be equipped to handle that nor
do they even want to a lot of times they
don't want to be in infantry because
they know it's going to be a lot of long
lonely nights they're going to be
fighting out the war
studying how to like shoot a gun which a
lot of them can't handle they can't
handle the kickback of a gun and then on
top of that they have to carry men which
i've i've been deployed i've had war
i've had blood in my hands nothing that
i wish neither of my worst enemies to
ever have seen go through things that i
never want to go through again and these
women the ones that did try to be in
infantry or combat jobs like tanking
they dropped out or they quit or they
asked to be repositioned in another job
in another department like
administration uh supply cooking um
uh what's the other job um combat medic
woman medic woman we need medic women
because you know why they have delicate
hands
they're able to go through insider
bodies and use their tiny hands their
fragile hands and they're delicate so
that's very important have a skill as a
woman men a lot of times unless you're a
surgeon and you have the
uh the resources in the in the hospital
it's different but for the most part
they don't belong in combat fields
because they know better and they know
for themselves they're not stupid women
are smart women
sometimes your friends are very smart i
actually i try to point this out i was
on because i'm on a volleyball team here
and i like pointed out the other day
just like how much harder men have it
than girls and i was like you know like
we're treated a lot better just because
we're females like people are nicer to
you well now you're treated a lot better
in a first world country because there
are women that are being oppressed in
third world countries that are dying
just like black men that are dying
and latino men
oh no for sure but i'm not like clearly
we're all for we're all from the states
we all grew up in a first world country
so that's right well i grew up i grew up
i grew up on more than one country
that's why i'm saying that yeah yeah no
i that's for sure but it's just
interesting how
like women are like in general are so
quick to like like be combative whenever
you like point out some of the benefits
that we get
including like
including like like court right like a
court system yeah yeah like if we go to
court and we get can me and you both get
convicted of the same crime i'm gonna
get a lighter sentence mostly
a lot of the advice i give to men who
are high earners who are men of status
of power i always tell them never marry
there's men there's one there's men that
i've uh i've hooked up with mexican
women and the other side of the border
they have a lavish style there because
the us dollar is worth so much in mexico
because the peso is so broke
a peso is a 30th of a duke of a u.s
dollar
so
um of one u.s dollar so over there they
lived like kings and queens and the
woman is a great cook is a great woman
she's a great cleaner of the house she's
a great mother um and they don't really
come back or fight their men and they
respect their men in mexico
a lot of the times are there's still a
few outliers there absolutely there's a
few i want to finesse and get the green
card absolutely i warn men i teach men
how to watch out for these type of women
um and the same thing i helped these
mexican women out there and said hey
these guys they're respectful this is
what they want that's what they're
looking for it's your time if you want
to go through that if you want to
experience that lifestyle the pros and
cons to it so uh that helped them out
and then some of these guys have gone to
colombia to brazil out of brazil because
of the high std hiv rate i tell them
never really hook up the women there
that much because it's so high
and uh venezuela argentina espana
uh all these places where it's not a
third world not a pro-feminist country
they're not they're very more second or
third world but they appreciate their
men so a lot of black men that have
helped have come to me and i've helped
them out with some of these most
gorgeous women some of these seven or
eights or nines or tens but they're
still humble they're grateful they're
very feminine they walk with smiles
they're not walking with the resting
[ __ ] face and they know they're lame
they know their place just like the men
know their place in another lane as
simple as that but in first world
countries like the uk like the us like
canada the women are going to die alone
and they deserve to die alone because
that's what they've earned that's what
they thought that they fed into this
crap and
you girls get what you get it's not
coming from a place of bitter anger it's
reality reality is sexist i know myron
says that on expression fit podcast but
it's true it's true well there's
benefits
and um
dis or benefits and pros and cons to a
woman there's pros and cons to a man in
life science biology for example i used
to be in a football player basketball
player mma fighter
when i was younger uh i would kick the
living [ __ ] out some of the women that
would come into that freaking gym most
of the time
it was every woman that ever tried to
step up to me in that class it is what
it is i was stronger faster than the
smarter
but yeah it's not because i hated a
woman it's the science doesn't hate you
it's just science
[Music]
and pearl have you ever met
first first up everything everything
mark said was right but have you ever
met a woman who's struggling from what i
call both ends where
where
once again
they've bought into this whole i need to
be strong and empowered and independent
but then they realize the reality that
they're not going to make as much as men
and they have a way out if they want it
but they just can't get over the hump
and accept the fact
that if if i don't want to be out here
as a single woman fighting fighting in
the world of men i need a man
do you have any friends that are kind of
at that point
and you can see him fighting against
this
against that that programming
um i don't really have that many friends
um
one of my friends is married and she
knows like damn well she could not
survive without her husband and my other
friend
probably like she's an engineer so she
probably actually will be able to
support herself
um because she's like
26 she makes like 70k a year shout out
shout out to her for being an engineer
because not many women choose to be
engineers
shout out to him no she's with the
biggest problem and she actually
she doesn't want to get married either
oh yeah oh you're saying that it
wouldn't happen but wait till she hits
33.
what
that's what i tell her i tried
i tried a red color but she doesn't
really know i'm telling you every single
woman i've met you know i'm from
the capital of washington state one of
the most liberal areas in the country
and if there are women i went to college
with
um
a graduate degree and stuff like that
that were bra burning feminists i hate
men and
now and
because
my group
we had kids the
the latest of any group
most of my friends who have kids have
kids when they're 33 and 34 years old
all these women
are with men now
really i had kids 33 34 these are women
that swore they'd never rely on a man
never get married but i'm telling you
when you hit your early 30s it's like
this biological biological imperative
that they cannot deny
mm-hmm
all of these
feminist friends are gonna find them
well it's it's interesting because i
tend to um do you know anything about
like your political leanings and like
personality traits
you know like
like so no no no no no no i don't
believe in that stuff um thank god thank
god no there's hope for you yet pearl
there's hope for you yet i don't know no
um but it's like if you're higher in the
tray openness you tend to be liberal
so openness is like your openness to new
experience like like that's why if
someone lives in a van you tend to think
that they're liberal because they're
only more conservative are they more
conservative i lean more conservative
that's the case i lean more conservative
i have some liberal tendencies but
majority it's conservative i'm more
conservative so so if um if a
conservative buys a dog they tend to buy
a dog to protect them if a liberal buys
a dog they tend to buy a dog that's like
fun
and i i have a fun dog and i'm very open
and if i take a personality test it says
i'm super liberal so i tend to get along
better with liberals but i'm actually
like super conservative so it's
interesting because like a lot of my
friends like believe in that stuff
because i like like i like high energy
people i like fun people so like when it
comes to the stuff
never matches and never matches if
you're pro male or pro black male you're
automatically labeled as a conservative
yeah because well
especially especially especially
in the black community everything is
black girl magic your black girl queens
are queens and that's whatever and what
they don't realize black girl magic has
run us into the ditch that's what they
want why do you i don't understand why
you get like a an award for just
existing
well that's everything this is the thing
you're gonna accomplish something sure
like then yeah
remember pearl
that's the same as equivalent to a
participation award so people now are
getting awards just for practice not
just existing not even participating
that's that's the sick joke now people
are not even participating they're
getting an award so my thing is uh two
two quick points my dog i play with her
um i have fun with her but she's a
protective dog as well so it's both so
it's kind of like i'm in the middle
um
but and then she's a fun dog but she's
fun with me but she protects me as well
and the second thing
you do you order a lot of amazon or do
you appreciate your amazon
oh my gosh i just got an amazon account
for the first okay
okay so because a lot of women
a lot of women take it for granted but i
guarantee you they don't go out of their
day to talk to their amazon delivery man
and they appreciate you thank him
a lot of times it's a man delivering to
your house so i guarantee you a lot of
women love amazon nowadays and they
don't even take that time to talk to the
amazon delivery person and thank him
yeah no that's true that's that's very
true absolutely
just saying
it just so so if i can you know i just
want to see
you know i gotta get off here a little
bit
i'm on the east coast but um yeah i just
hope that you can like when you're
hearing certain black manosphere people
talk kevin samuels o'shea
jackson uh you know
freshman fit uh hey
and honestly like i started looking at
him different ever since you
you went on there because like
your two would
were some of the best
uh
episodes on there um
uh but it's just
uh as black men we've been starved
for empowerment
starved
like
starved as a community
and so
when you hear people going extreme or
you hear people saying these things like
a lot
it's because you know
it's a pendulum you know it goes like
this then it goes like this and then it
even goes
in the middle so right now the
manuscript particularly black ministry
it's swinging back and forth we hear
people saying
saying exchange it's going to take maybe
five or ten years
to kind of figure it out but you know
i'm loving every second of it because
you know because i still think about
myself you know you know you know i was
a kid in high school that was too you
know i was a black kid that you know
i was
you know i used to skate and listen to
rock music and stuff and all the black
girls like you actually what the way
that i speak getting good grades
and guys like kevin samuels and all them
yeah i kind of heard that like
now i'm here to tell all of you
gentlemen
get to 35 don't have any children don't
get married and the world will open up
to you listen guys like kevin samuels oh
say duke jackson because once again my
generation
all we did was vote with our feet
none of us had children none of us got
married
now we're triggering now we're trying to
figure out what to do and
kevin samuels and a lot of those guys
made my childhood experience and my
college years make sense
like i always knew something was up but
i'm looking i'm looking at the mastery
content now and looking back at my life
and saying oh okay
you got you young guys
you get to listen to it
even you pearl you get to see it now
imagine being my age and looking back on
it and
having these guys on the internet
my dad was a great dad
don't get me wrong
but
there have been pieces of the puzzle
that
kevin samuels and other guys have kind
of put together and
have made me look back and make more
sense so
enjoy it while it's here enjoy the rise
enjoy enjoy while it's being created and
it even people like you pearl
i'm glad that you could contribute to to
think such in such a small way because i
wouldn't do the time where all there was
especially
the vacuuming which is playing out
misandry unanswered unadulterated
unfiltered misandry
so
um enjoy this while this is here the
demand is free it's new it's figured
it's figuring itself out and hopefully
in five continuing years all the crazies
will be gone
and we'll have a little bit more
structure
okay well thanks for coming on i
appreciate it thanks for being a
supporter and keep up the good content
pearl
enjoy england
thank you dublin ireland and belfast but
never never england
oh yeah i love it here so far it's been
cool come here okay bye
bye
yeah this is crazy
yeah it's crazy there's a break-in in my
building the other day and the cops just
like don't come
like you know what you know
well since you live in the uk you should
have called the feminists maybe they
would have come or they would call the
cops for you they would call the cops
for you i don't know
i mean it wasn't my building it was like
the building next door to me but i was
like what the they just don't come but
pearl but pearl you're a woman you're a
feminist you don't need a man you don't
need a man but
i'm not
um no no i'm not calling you i'm just
saying because the uk is very feminist
it's very feminist strong strong angel
and ninja55 i need you guys to do you
guys want to talk
hey so i'm a big fan i've been watching
the show for a while i agree with
everything
that the black dude that just got off
everything he was saying it sounds a
little bit like marcus is incredibly
frustrated though
um was that was that the guy that sorry
i'm not good with names was that the guy
that just left
you get that vibe or was it just me
that he was fresh hey how you doing
oh hi
oh did the okay that guy just left okay
um
i no i didn't really notice i thought he
was just like passionate i thought he
was like frustrated with um
the
experience that he had i guess yeah yeah
no that's what i meant no not with you
just you know he sounded like he was
frustrated in general yeah
there is a lot of good women out here
man uh you just gotta get out and meet
him you know um
i don't think every woman's a feminist
i don't think even the majority are
i think
maybe he just has a good woman what do
you mean in the state or what do you
what do you mean like in the states or
overseas
yeah i'm in the states
i'm in texas oh
geez i guess it probably worked for you
because me don't really work each woman
in the states really are mean to me and
they're you know always been mean to me
you know probably because i'm i'm short
and everything you know
uh it's a lot of short women too man i
mean i'm not the tallest ever but how
tall are you
me i'm five foot seven
oh that's that's fine i mean for like
girls that are like the average girl is
five five
that's true
but
these females
and it's probably because i'm picky too
you know i mean
hey
you know
and always been picky a lot you know the
reason why is because
i'm unattractive you know and i have
confidence because people told me oh my
friend told me oh you don't have no
confidence saying you're on the tractor
because even if i'm unattractive you
know i still use game and everything
have used games it still didn't work but
hey i kept crying how how often do you
like go out a week and like try stuff
how often do i go out a week
yeah like um
five times a week or something five days
a week
or anything you go you go out five times
a week and you try to like talk to girls
yeah but
i i i stopped it and everything you know
because it wasn't really really no use
at all because
i remember um
at this college when i was would speak
to these girls and everything
it was well it was it was these college
girls when i spoke to these college
girls and everything i always speak to
them it was just college i it was this
college library opens to the public like
people
can use this college library you know
regular people you know and then it'll
be the college people so i would speak
to these girls something when college
let
out and these college girls they all
lied on me and said i was harassing them
which i wasn't all i was doing was just
speak to them saying hello how you doing
you know it was just ridiculous so it's
like man
and then anytime i speak to these
females out here ignore me like recently
some girl
told me oh um
well i spoke to her and then she's like
um
i started to talk to her some more but
then she said i gotta go to work go away
so it's like oh never mind
you know
yeah um
have you ever tried to have like a coach
or something like a dating coach or
someone that could like help you
because i mean
well you should try that because you
tried working on yourself bro i know you
said you're unattractive do you work out
or do anything to
fix that
yeah i have but
i i've been like
kind of like working i've been lifting
weights you know i have weights at home
but
these places here i've been trying to
work out i was working at this gym and
everything but this gym is like uh
like a lot of these gyms are scams it's
like you know you got to um you need
your credit card number and then all of
a sudden
when you want to leave this gym you know
that you they charge you on some other
fees i haven't you haven't heard of it's
like come on man
yeah but it's like it's like 50 bucks
like it's not that much yeah man if you
if you think the big problem is you
being unattractive
there's things you can do for that you
know and and i promise you once you get
one
as soon as you get a number
it always works like this as soon as you
get one number you're gonna get 10 more
you know yeah i think it's just i don't
know what it is but that's how it works
i've never i i've never met a guy that's
like so unattractive that like no girl
would ever like want to date him or talk
to him
um with that like was doing everything
possible
you know
um so i'd really recommend that you like
get a coach that could like help you
with like whatever you need
so like if you if you yeah like there's
dating coaches or even just having a
friend like help go make you approach
girls and like tell you what he sees you
can even have like a friend do that
yeah i mean and another thing is you
know you like the guy who's on who's
um
he said how you know
what it is with these women over here is
um these women over here in the states
they got white collar jobs a lot of them
got white collar jobs like i say like 40
of women got white collar jobs you know
which means they they that means they
really think they don't need a man you
know which is ridiculous you know
yeah but
like there's older women like if you
there's girls that are like 31 and
looking for a guy like i'm just saying
like you just seem really like hopeless
and i don't think it's hopeless for you
um
i think like
like it can always get better you know
but if you like believe that gyms are a
scam and you believe and you're not like
going out and approaching women
constantly like how can you say that
well
the thing about with the gems is
you know they charge these fees like
this gym i don't know you heard this gym
called sweat
[ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta pay a job you
gotta get a job and play the [ __ ] gym
stop making yourself
you sound pathetic it's pathetic
well that's not be mean to the guy but i
mean come yeah but i mean for real i'm
blunt i'm blunt [ __ ]
you do gotta get it together man you're
making excuses talking about fees what
do you what do you what do you do
do you have a job
do i have a job yeah i'm working
okay well as what
i'll i'll i work as a bar back
as a bar back okay so hold on i'm doing
something somewhere so so so what do you
make like hourly
well
i make they pay me ten thousand dollars
and the tips you know i make good money
in debt you know really good
okay so what would you say you take home
like monthly
i'll probably take like home one for
2 000
2 000 a month
yeah i'm pretty good at it
yes
so it's 20 you make 24 000 a year you'd
say
probably
okay
how old am i
yeah
why do you want to know my [ __ ] age
you spit
speak
i'm black okay
well your name
your name
rodriguez
that wasn't me who said it that wasn't
me who said it it was angel
it was angel
okay
i mean no one your username your
username is ninja55 like no one knows
who you are
um
so if anything you could maybe get some
good advice out of this but like no one
can see you no one knows who you are
oh all right you know i mean i i know
i'm doing the right thing
that got hella weird really quick
yeah you sound like a weirdo growing a
pedophile
and a racist
all right let's just get
okay i removed him from the stream
can we just all agree that that was
probably his
main problem he was hateful yeah it
sounds like he's a no offense i'm going
to say
he's an [ __ ] sounds kind of pervy
he's desperate he needs to get his money
up and get his weight down and that's it
that'll be fine
why does someone trying to join the
stream
that's like working out
that's just
i was just really out of pocket like it
didn't have to go there i don't take
offense to it i don't take events too i
don't care
i mean i'm not gonna like go oh i'm home
i'm not gonna go to my bed and like cry
about i'm like
i mean you wanna be like that in real
life though like come on
he just shows us
he shows probably doesn't have patience
with women either
bro you working out
yeah you're trying not to be a fat ass
that's what you have to do
and i guess real quick on that and you
know working out helps but i mean a lot
of it's in your diet too bro why do you
care you [ __ ] spit
what i'm i'm still shocked
i mean well i was just like you could
you like clearly no one knows who he is
like you could just tell us your age
what is it like i was trying i was i was
actually defending angel because he that
was technically meant for angel but he
thought it was me
i didn't know what that meant actually
i didn't i didn't
he thought it was me but it was actually
calling angels [ __ ] and that's a
derogatory word they call mexicans it's
like the same as saying the n word with
the er at the end for a black version
it means uh it stands for
spanish person in custody i believe it's
uh not something you tell a friend so
yeah you can get cancer for that
sometimes nowadays
i'm uh i'm a mexican guy living overseas
so i don't hear racial slurs all the
time
well what part uh where do you live
overseas i live in hong kong
okay yeah i was kind of like depending
like if you were like somewhere in
france uh i could i guess like they're
probably saying stuff about you but uh
probably french though i mean i i speak
chinese but like
i i don't you never hear it you know
what i mean
yeah it's it's very interesting because
uh one point i used to know three
languages english um in german and
french and then people would just like
say things like not thinking that like
especially when i was in france i was
like 15
and obviously you look very american so
they're probably like oh this kid
doesn't know what's going on and i was
just scared and i'm just like damn
yeah but speaking to the to the thing
about like getting in shape
and working on yourself like i used to
be like 320 pounds
at the beginning of 2021
and i dropped down to like 255 right now
so like a sexy beast you a sexy beast
it makes a big difference bro how people
how people look at you how people like
respect you whenever you go into the
store bro like the doors open for you
yeah and i wasn't totally different and
i i don't know if it was like people
were referring to like the very
beginning or i guess at least from my
perspective like what i was saying i'm
not saying like oh no man you know just
lay at home blame the world you know you
don't have to do anything your purpose
oh i get it um
you know even though i'm only 22 y'all
um not too long ago i actually had a
stroke and
so i couldn't speak or walk i couldn't
see out of my left eye so i completely
get i completely get having to like you
know kind of pick yourself up but you
got to be careful with that stuff like
if you're just like so like if you
become extremely self-absorbed it's very
easy to just become a mass [ __ ]
thinks he's above everyone everyone else
is wrong everyone else is x y and z and
then like okay you can be super like yo
even him
he's saying that he's short he's five
seven i'm like my dude like i know guys
that are five three like they have it
hard bro just had every excuse in the
book
five seven he didn't like that
the average girl's five five and like
half of girls are shorter than her and
mac uh to remind that to thank you uh i
appreciate that you survived that my
mother she had a stroke and an aneurysm
at the same time and it was a miracle
that she made it so i appreciate that
you got the strength to get back up on
that because it's a stroke and aneurysms
if they take you they take you in that
moment so you must have some real strong
strength and some miracle from god
because
uh i do believe in god i do believe in
god and believe in miracles but possibly
the science of it but uh you know uh my
mom went through that and she's still
picking herself up she's still not the
same her equilibrium is off she's taking
medication she's had the she had to be
on steroids when that first happened
and um
yeah she had collapsed literally buying
presents like the day before christmas
this was like 2011.
and i remember it because
uh i was at school and i was going
through uh you know my school life went
through sports and then i had gone to
argue with my parents and then the i was
staying with my brother for a little bit
and then that happened the day before
christmas
and after that just like it's like you
cannot take every day for granted we
came to my mom
and she had that and i couldn't believe
that she made it because the doctors
were saying she only had like a 50
chance so
when that happened
[ __ ] like she did everything she could
she lost like 70 80 pounds or so from
just because she wasn't even a lot of
weight
lucky
i lost my appetite for a while but so
basically how it happened to me it was
actually yeah it was last uh fall
semester for me you know just about to
wrap up finals so i was like okay cool
switched everything else you know i just
have these last two to do and i go to
bed one time and you know i had a
headache but i was like i just took like
four engineering finals you know it
happens and from my perspective i just
like wake up in a hospital uh
room like
however long ago that was from having
the start of the stroke my parents was
literally trying to take me to the
hospital and i and i'm just looking
around like i couldn't see because of uh
nerve damage
has thankfully gotten a lot better
and i was like okay and i just look like
this and i'm like okay i have staples on
my head so like i'm thinking like okay
did i fall my nurse looks at me like nah
dude you had an aneurism and i'm just
like no [ __ ] way yeah
did they take out did when they did the
aneurysm for you
um did they take out the cranium the
it's like called the cranium or the
cranium yeah yeah in the back okay did
so they sawed off the bone in the back
of the skull
[Music]
yeah because for my mom they had to pump
out the blood back in the cranium
um and uh she had surmassed like a huge
clot in her brain
that if she if they had if she had
waited a little bit longer
um before checking her to the hospital
she would have died right there because
it was literally on points of bursting
and then it somewhat burst but it would
still be well it was still
i don't know how but they were trying to
explain it to me i just didn't believe
it but they were able to uh pump the
fluid out from the blood because it was
so caught up
it was it was crazy
yeah
yeah there's a process though like she
had to wait to get physical therapy she
was in that hospital she was like in the
icu like i don't mean you can understand
being in the icu
and then throwing up for everything she
got out of you right now
yeah like when she got up and walked and
was doing her physical therapy every
time she was like throwing up buckets
and buckets full of like
whatever they were giving her pumping
her that food through the needle
the to the fluid the food
food fluid whatever
yeah like a big tube
yeah the two there you go the feeding
tube and so she kept throwing up and she
would fill the buckets full of throw up
and she would get so thin
she would get so thin and um
and then she was able to eat she was
like finally so she started pigging out
and like ordering so every time we visit
her we bring her whatever she want a
sushi or whatever chinese or like
italian
so
i can only imagine how hungry you were
when you started eating again
yeah um so i
i the last time i was like really
weighing myself i was like ironically
enough actually trying to like go down a
little bit because i was thinking back
then i was going to be like a serious
like um
mountain biker so i was going to like
start racing and do all that and it's
like very weight competitive like those
guys like mountain bikes
they do not have
any extra fat or muscle that isn't like
extremely necessary so i had to go from
like i was like 150
um then
and when i got out of hospital weight
myself first time i was at 160. so i
lost uh 20 uh
25 35 just from that earth
i don't know it's late and i can't
i lost a lot
but uh
yeah so it's uh it was it was crazy
crazy bro you were weighing less than
like ronda rousey
yeah uh
so it was it was like ironic i was like
yeah man i i need to like kind of like i
wasn't like like super obsessed as well
i was thinking like uh it'll be nice if
i can get to that point stay strong you
know at least on a bike and start racing
but like i little did i know like i
would actually end up losing that weight
but just no
no i did it would be in that way so
so you were always like
okay so you were always a pretty lean
guy though you're always a lean guy okay
so that was
you never had a factor of being fat okay
yeah and for for like reference i'm like
roughly six feet i know like practically
every guy says that i just i mean
i'm i'm actually six feet so
yeah
you know
what like why do and you're i don't know
anything about aneurysms is it just
random or just stuff stress a lot of it
says it's stress you say it's a
buildable trust they usually say that
wow and then sometimes it's like and if
you're like and i guess if you're like
super worried about it if you ever had
an mri before um in your brain for
whatever reason if you have like uh
epilepsy you'll probably see it so if
that helps you sleep a little bit more
at night i don't know so
um
yeah
so like i get like you know like
literally having to like pick yourself
up because i used to not not be able to
really like speak or like really do much
so it's so like i completely get it but
like kind of just like one thing i see
that kind of happens to a lot of people
in general it's like like i see like in
a west that uh generally so we can we
have a very individually focused culture
we're all about like oh you know you
know just just focus on your grind just
focus on you know just just
just focus on you you know
bob xyz will come later which i get but
it's also like
you know
when most people were like and i like
have this experience like when you're
thinking like you're when it's close to
your time going you're not thinking
about like how much oh i made like this
amount of money
oh i you know drive
this car i have this amount of shoes
blah blah blah you're thinking about
like nah
what if i asked what if i asked that
girl out that one time what if what have
that could have been or oh i wish i
talked to my parents more stuff is
that's what you're really thinking about
yeah
just to remind you like there's and
there's obviously a purpose and a reason
why you survived that so it's obviously
that your time wasn't up and you have a
purpose in this earth so
uh just keep striving for whatever you
want to be and whatever you want to
become so don't give up and obviously
you have it so you're still here for a
reason and a purpose
yeah
you know are you in college are you in
college right now yeah about trying to
job it's been very interesting um
what's your major
uh i chose the easy one so it's a
mechanical engineering so
how much is that like starting off like
how many how much what's your wage on
that like what's the starting wage on
that for like yearly annual income
my brother's at 90 like four years in i
don't know what it stuck he started at
yeah here in atlanta i'm looking at like
60k starting off and that's like if i
don't really like negotiate which i
could do but like to be honest at this
point like yeah
money's nice you know i'm broke right
now actually thinking i might have to
you know
are you a student
have you taken out loans
oh hell yeah dude
oh you [ __ ] up
oh you fall
you know bills don't pay themselves so i
did what i did what i had to do but it's
all right um
speaking of that like i i get like to
want for money because like i'm actually
like just to keep it up full stack i'm
actually
and
from medical debt actually i'm looking
very likely you don't have to file
bankruptcy soon so i like get being
broke but it's like ah you know money
comes and goes like
there are no atms in heaven so it's like
i don't know but the thing is like the
thing was like growing up with like a
dad that was like my dad was gone like a
lot a lot growing up barely saw him but
like he because he was so successful
like i get to see him all i want now
like i literally get to do like true
like the thing about like making a lot
of money and providing like a lot enough
for a family is like
you get to spend time that like other
people don't get
you know what i mean like he can pay for
all of us to like
go anywhere in the world for a week and
just spend time together as a family
like no one else gets to do that and so
a lot of times like what people don't
realize about having money is it like
unlocks the ability to spend more time
with your family
that's true i saw i guess i lucked out a
bit with that kind of growing up and i
guess if you could call it luckily
with the pandemic my dad just works at
home now and i'm constantly going
between here and college so i had to see
him a lot more often now so
i heard that the majority majority of
female workers when they were given the
option to come back to work from the
pandemic they decided to stay at home
and work from home to kids be with their
kids
a lot of jobs it's a wrap like
yeah thank you for the donation guys
there's a couple people that donated um
i actually had a question i was gonna
ask since we have like a lot of people
um it's very off topic though
that's fine all right who do you guys
think gets wifed up faster prudes or
hoes
hoes um
my experience because i live overseas
crudes
fruits juice yeah i i gotta i i
[Music]
i got a uga and it's like a big sec
school you know everyone
supposedly is mostly christian there but
you know you look behind the bell
yeah i mean
well well here's the thing like i like
you mac you're cool
i was i was like a virgin for most of
college like the majority of it and the
thing is like i felt like it was harder
to get a relationship because like most
guys like wanted to sleep with you
before they would like wife you
and like i felt are like like be in a
relationship with you
and i felt like i would see like the
[ __ ] or the friend the quicker she
like would get in a relationship and
like get married to be honest which is
kind of like the opposite of what the
man of sphere says but you know that
also backfires on a lot of women yeah
yeah that could too if the girl is too
much of a free spirit too much of i'm
gonna keep more respectful and say she's
more of a free sexual spirit uh
yeah she it could backfire but you know
it is what it is
it's pros and cons pros and cons
no i don't really like care one way or
the other it's just interesting like
i've listened to like
hours and hours and hours of men talk
right and they all say they want a girl
that's like
like hasn't done a lot and experience
then fine you know great but it just
isn't what i've seen in the real world
like what i've seen is like my friends
that sleep with more people like tend to
get in relationships faster
yeah because obviously guys like one
have the sex they they want they're
pursuing the sex and if you make the guy
wait for it it's kind of like you
deserve to get ghosted because you
waited too long made the guy wait too
long
um if you cough it up i say i'm a cable
girl makes me wait like two or three or
four weeks i'm fine with that but we
just won't date as much we just want to
dance
and you know i guess what i'll say um
yeah i could see why you know people who
you know you know super hot get married
quicker i guess it's like
at least for me you know
i i mean i am probably the youngest
person here but like i mean hey if you
put yourself out more there uh put
yourself out there more
you want to
just get more action whether that's you
know bedroom or a relationship or just
because i feel like
like sex is like a shot at a
relationship but kind of like if a guy
goes on more dates right like the odds
of him getting later quicker like i feel
like a girl if she sleeps with more guys
like the odds of her finding one that
like it's compatible and he like likes
her back is like more because it's more
like
shots at it does that make sense
yeah
i have a boyfriend so i i don't care you
know but it's just like it's just what
i've like strictly seen
i want to ask y'all real quick with me
and my personal experience i feel like
that's a good way for women to weed out
men that aren't really interested by
making them awake in my own personal
experience yeah i feel like yeah i can
be whatever you want
up until i get it
and then bam you know i might just [ __ ]
around and ghost you you know
but i'm not going to do something
who i'm genuinely interested in
you know
and i feel like
or am i tripping i know there's no no i
get that it's definitely like a a form
of a test um but i was thinking and this
is like specific to uga i'm not saying
like any of you i i get like being blue
collar not in college like i think like
they are part of it's like a scam anyway
but like at uga it's like so studious
and uga it's just the university of
georgia like it's so studious but i'll
say like uh you know if you put yourself
out more there i wasn't even thinking
necessarily in compatibility it's like
no i know like a lot of like you know my
my um peers especially engineering like
there's just a lot of people who just
like just don't socialize we're all
[ __ ] busy so
like i know like a lot of a lot of my
friends are chicks like they just like
they
kind of like me for a little bit we just
go to class go home and that's just life
for a while
but uh you know why they do you know
they like you do you know they like you
i can tell you why they like you
there's three things you're you have a
chill personality
bbc and you're six foot tall
i guess
the three things
no no no
yeah
but um i guess to say to the other thing
a little bit earlier we're kind of like
um like kind of how i feel about body
pal it's not that like oh you know she's
been with like so so-and-so amount of
people before and it wasn't me i'm like
sitting there like punching the air like
how could you
it's more like
it's just more like kind of a bit what
correlates and kind of what comes with
that a little bit like again i'm not
like i'm i guess i would say like
slightly religious i'm not active in a
church so it's i'm not even coming at
that from like that angle it's just like
what i kind of see what kind of comes
around from people who kind of lift that
kind of like fast life
it doesn't even have to necessarily be
like you know bedroom action it could
just be drugs
hardcore drinking partying all that it's
just like uh like
they just kind of stopped being people
after a while like all they
live for is like the next fix and like
you can't have like a halfway serious
conversation with them they don't have
any like real values and morals and it
kind of gets all being around them are
you are you talking about young girls
you're talking about young people i'm
talking about yeah yeah well you're 22.
so i'd imagine like the girls around
your age right
yeah because a lot of a lot of the girls
and again this is because of the society
the first west uh western first world
country a lot of sexual liberation and
feminism and this equality and like the
sayings of like these [ __ ] advice
that women give to other women because
single women keep others see keep other
women single or they get them single
and and so the thing is
they say you go girl you can do no wrong
you're not fat chick you're just p-h-a-t
you're fat you know you're you're
different you're loving
yeah and and remember this because i
remember there was a guy named brandon
brandon something uh he was a well-known
guy in the freshman fit upon he was a
guest he's saying he said that almost
every day 1400 people are dying of heart
related obesity issues or obesity or
being fat people are dying okay this
weekend this is going to be in my vlog
but i literally got this conversation on
camera because i got this conversation
on camera with two girls from my team um
it was so
me and another girl on my team she's
like six three i'm like six foot they
were like the tall girls on the team and
we were saying how we both want to lose
like 20 pounds and like she wants to
lose like 30 i want to lose 20. and this
other girl on the team was like oh you
guys are beautiful just the way we are
and we're like yeah like we were like
yeah but we'd be like hotter 20 pounds
lighter i don't understand like why this
is a big deal and like she kept arguing
with us we're like oh you're beautiful
at any size you don't have to do this
and i'm like i don't you have to but
well i think that's the the thing the
thing that people need to understand
that just because you're skinny that
doesn't mean you're healthy
healthy means you are you are packing
your body with a lot of uh zinc and
magnesium amino acids proteins i used to
be a trainer a nutritionist i still kind
of am part-time but
but you need to fill your bodies up with
amino acids zinc and magnesium proteins
all this
wait i need you to help me
yeah i'll do it for free i'll do it for
free no i swear to god i'm gonna tell
you what i i've been like trying to eat
the same things so i can like keep it
under a certain calorie because
otherwise i just get really confused
tell me
are you doing a calorie deficit are you
doing calorie deficit to lose weight
okay that's perfect perfect yeah because
i'm i'm doing semi-pro volleyball now so
i get i burn like 2 700 calories on
average a day which is like that i
should have said tense so if you if you
if you eat about 1500 to 2000 calories
you'll be fine because you're burning
more than you eat so you'll be fine you
just got to split your meals
and
have healthy snacks that are very low to
zero calories and zero carbs those are
the two main things and also make sure
that the foods don't have a lot of
saturated fat if they do a couple grams
of saturated fat are good but not too
much like two or three grams is fine and
then the sugars the sugars if you're
going to eat foods that have certain
sugars make sure they're in the low
single digits as well
um that was my key purpose when i was i
managed going from like 30 body fat to
like eight percent and i was like ripped
up rambo basically i was in the military
when i was like special forces and stuff
um what you do is you you get a lot of
vegetables if you're gonna eat if you're
craving a candy bar just get a fruit
that's common sense um eat a salad with
your chicken don't eat a lot of pasta
bread tortillas none of that rice not a
lot very little um if you want to be low
carb and that's the best way for a
calorie deficit and on top of that
um forget about eating late is that
that's that's a lie depending on your
sleeping pattern and what your scheduled
gym you can eat a healthy meal just not
a heavy healthy meal a light healthy
meal and a protein shake at night
let's say you come from the gym at 11 or
12 at midnight like i used to sometimes
i used to have a small meal and then
just my protein shake and that would
fill up my my my my body up for that
time um and then in the morning when you
wake up you go out for a run for about
45 minutes to an hour um like a decent
jog to like 80 max speed
um and you eat it and you go running on
an empty stomach you never go with
something if you are eat a banana and
have like a black coffee
um yeah because
if you don't have because if you don't
drink a fat burning you can take a fat
burner that helped me too but you can
also drink black coffee in a banana
um
so is rice bad that's that was my
question rice rice rice in the
moderation
i have a lemon i've eliminated pastas
and like pizza like i don't eat those
anymore
um like my like i look at i used to okay
like so so
so so list and bread i don't eat bread
either so okay so you've eliminated you
you've eliminated bread pasta
yeah and um you related pizza so what
you're going to do is you're going to
eliminate fast food you're going to
eliminate chips ice cream soda you're
going to eliminate chocolate anything
that basically brings you joy you're
going to eliminate
and yeah and
you have to sacrifice that but there's
there's fruits though so there's a lot
of fruits that are high in sugar
but i always say this would you rather
eat watermelon or a hershey chocolate
bar i go with the watermelon because
it's essential okay
oh um can i speak for a second yeah go
ahead what's up so you can always just
find like status quo for those stuff so
like you can try cause our rice or even
pasta made from chickpeas and those work
really well too
yeah those two
yeah yeah i was going to say the same
thing
a lot of people don't like cauliflower
so i say if you're not going to eat
cauliflower
eat peas eat spinach eat the greener the
vegetable the better i remember when i
was in high school that was one of the
things that my personal trainer taught
me the greener the vegetable the more
antioxidants the more minerals the more
vitamins the more amino acids nutrients
fiber it'll have in it so you're going
to be going to the bathroom constantly
you're going to be pooping and [ __ ]
and like peeing you're gonna have to
drink like about a gallon because you're
an athlete you have to drink about a
gallon and a half a day at least
no no more than a gallon and a half
um you'll be fine with that because
you're constantly running i know you
said you're volleyball or something
you're volleyball or basketball yeah i
play
i play both at the school okay well then
there you go because you because you
play two sports you're going to need
definitely amino acids zinc and
magnesium because you do not want to get
injured
what's the best place to get that it's
in connecticut i eat a lot of salmon
right now
okay that's perfect perfect perfect okay
so salmon is one of the best like um
it's one of the best because i eat it
with rice like sushi oh okay okay
so no no no no no so the thing is if you
want if you want to cook it lightly
do it with like coconut oil or avocado
oil um yeah and the thing about salmon
is it's it has the healthy fats
so if you want to do ever a ketosis diet
do it temporarily but i would stick to
the calorie deficit
and for the pasta just like just get
like a handful of your hand measure your
hand and that's the amount of pasta you
should put on your plate on your hand oh
that's so good that's such a good i hate
weighing it i hate it so
and remember when you do the chicken
serving
uh do your palm not your fingers but do
your palm and the palm is really the
size of the portion you're supposed to
be eating from your palm of your hand
and that's a good amount of chicken
okay and on top of that drink your
protein shake with it because you might
want you might want to add some muscle
because i know for volleyball you've got
to have strong legs and power and then
for basketball you've got to have
overall body uh calisthenics plyometrics
um yeah because i love i love playing
basketball but injuries [ __ ] me up a
little bit here and there and as far as
i just like to eat that's my problem
yeah i don't know and it's also because
you're tall because you're like six foot
and um on top of that uh for you um
the one of the muscles you can work out
every day is is abs so core you can work
out literally like every workout you
work out you can literally work out core
like squats itself works out your core
but you can literally do like straight
ab hitters like every time you work out
and that's why people that have six
packs is because they're working out
their core consistently
and um on top of that you gotta make
sure you get at least eight hours of
sleep
and then wake up on an empty stomach do
your interval do speeding do a lot of
sprints
um
and that'll be there are some serious
gains right there because yes
because sprints actually burn fat burn
springs like that i used to run track
and i still do a little bit of cycling
but like for any sort of like like
serious long-term durians and like being
a dual sport athlete i can imagine
because that is
like yeah you make a lot of your
endurance gains from when you're on an
empty stomach you have no um collagen i
believe in your muscles so you're like
completely flat you're actually you
start burning fat because your your
body's like oh [ __ ] i need to get energy
somewhere how do you so how do you deal
with okay yo i used i'm like
i before i've been like trying to be
better you know um i used to eat like a
lot of sugar and i've cut back a lot but
like recently i've been doing like when
i have sugar cravings i've been doing
like bananas and peanut butter smoothie
um is that bad
oh it depends on depends depends on the
brand of peanut butter and it depends on
how tart the um the banana is because
banana has stages where it's so sugary
and so the earlier the age of the banana
the better because it has like it's
going to be kind of green it's going to
be kind of green and yellow but it's
less sugar but it's not as ripe so i've
learned that trick i've learned that
trick to through potassium it contains
more potassium when it has less sugar in
the starch um because even though those
are healthy sugar starches um
what happens is what happens is when you
have these uh strongly condensed sugar
starches it's harder to break down and
that's why um a lot of these high salty
high sugary fat foods that are saturated
um they go to your love handles they go
to your hips they go to your belly and
then you have to work you have to work a
month off of abs to burn it off
sometimes um these things that you're
eating throughout the week so if i were
you i just don't eat soda sugary drinks
yeah um stay away from starbucks stay
away from starbucks
actually i've been sober from starbucks
for like a month so you could say that's
progress and the thing about and the
thing about salmon salmon is uh
salmon is great in omega omega so it's
good for your joints your your hair your
ligaments your bones
i love the salmon that's like my
favorite thing is like i'll do rice
salmon and avocado and i just like mix
it with the sesame seeds and the um
oil
yeah yeah okay what kind of oil do you
use because oils kind of kill your diet
do oils do
yeah
damn um sesame oil i've been using i
think that's something it is
um that's not as bad as like vegetable
oil because vegetable oil is actually
pretty bad because it's um it's
manufactured so you got to look into
these things so for me i looked at it
from a young age so like a vegetable oil
is like one of the worst things you can
get because it's so saturated so is corn
oil so which so what you do is
no no olive oil is good olive oil is
great i said vegetable oil vegetable oil
is the one that it says it right there
mixture of it um so
extra extra virgin olive oil is good um
i i use coconut avocado and extra virgin
depending on which one i'm feeling that
day and then on top of that the chicken
i usually put in the oven my chicken and
then on top of that um
i use i can't believe it's not butter
because it's like zero everything so
it's kind of a guilty pleasure and it's
zero calories zero fat everything and
then um i like to use sriracha um i'm
mexican because i like spicy food
so oh yeah like bell peppers
bell peppers can be a good snack if you
eat them raw i bet
most of the time when people
get the best at other vegetables and
what they eat them wrong that's the best
just wash them off rinse them off
i hate vegetables i hate 90 of us but
the
that
thing
is
super power food though the vegetables
are super powerful and um
and along with your so bad
no no no no no no no
cucumbers cucumbers
carrots
so good they're bombs
i'm gonna jump in real quick about um
sorry so it and so if you can't rock
with vegetables that's fine but um kind
of go a tiny bit and we'll hop back to
the vegetable but to talk a little bit
about fruit
if you're going to have sugar have it be
fruits because
the sugars and fruits while probably
yeah they're going to still give you a
little bit of insulin um
resistance and that's another thing i'm
over here i'm i'm i'm tripping i'm this
is like a no calorie uh drink but i buy
those two
the thing is even with these you have to
be a little bit careful if you're if you
have a family history of diabetes like
artificial sweeteners still give you
insulin resistance so like if you think
like you're safe to go with like diet
coke or whatever you still got to be
careful but uh with fruit with
sugar and fruits since it's like so kind
of tightly locked up in fiber it's
actually
it it actually spikes your insulin a lot
less
so if you're that's what you're
concerned about well now i know like
we're talking about earlier like you can
be thin
but so unhealthy
um so i don't know it's just like
diabetes in my family something like i
have to worry about so even though i'm
like the lightest i've ever been it's
still like you can't just be like i
don't know like eating chocolate for fun
but um with vegetables like you gotta
you gotta try like cajun cooking to be
honest like
just i do i do like spice it up a little
bit so
like like yeah so
i like occasion too i like it i like
spicy
yeah for me i love chinese no you're
good you're good i love chinese food i
love italian food um so like for example
instead of having a cheat day this is a
trick for you a lot of a lot of um
trainers won't tell you this because
they want to keep you coming back to the
trainer to pay them um
instead of having a cheat day once a
week have a cheat day like every three
weeks or four weeks
um because that way you'll be
consistently seeing your body form and
change and it'll be staying away from
that cheat day which means it's going to
want you to crave that cheat day more um
so that way you can have an entire cheat
day so you can have like two meals of
cheating and like a snack of cheating
that day that you get it but um push
push back the cheat day make it every
three weeks or four weeks and then
you'll appreciate that cheat day more
and then you'll push yourself harder and
harder and that'll be your reward is
that cheat day and then on top of that
um uh
uh like the chicken the chicken you you
like you said chicken salmon you're
doing good in um add some bison because
it's it's a lot of protein bison it's
great protein um you can still
take
steak
steak you can just um smaller portions
of steak
okay smaller portions high calorie
uh no uh what what well kind of but more
importantly it's because it's the red
meat so red meat it kind of goes more
into your stomach area and that can be
sometimes harder to burn um it also
depends on the
the amount the amount of protein because
steak does have a lot of protein it's
great protein in it um however
um you gotta understand that red meat is
like more cholesterol in it as well
um so i have like steak every now and
then i don't have it occasionally i have
it every now and then you can spice it
up so put it in once a week into your
once a week into your uh
weekly intake
um or twice a week maybe if you want to
um i know that you can use a little bit
of shrimp a little bit of shrimp is fine
it's not going to kill you
um
and then also
ground turkey ground turkey if you want
i know it doesn't taste the best but if
you add the right ingredients to it
yeah
i like i like ground turkey
much of a different world to be honest
yeah i like ground turkey bro yeah it's
only good it's only good if you mix the
right vegetables it's good and then
don't add a lot of oils but if you are
going to add the oil say the ones i said
earlier
avocado coconut or extra virgin olive
oil and then um
you can add some spices to it that
tastes good
paprika red peppers
red pepper flakes um
and
black pepper
i like to squeeze a little bit of lemon
after i cook it as it's done cooking i
add some lemon and pepper to my food
and maybe a sauce here and there that's
a spicy sauce that's like low sodium or
no sodium
and
instead of eating potato chips
try to find uh
what's those other chips that i uh
i don't i genuinely i don't eat potato
chips or anything i just i'm addicted to
like candy and sugar that's like my
problem is i'll i'll do good for like
three days or four days and then i'll
just like crave sugar so bad well there
is a chocolate that you can eat during
your diet there's a chocolate that you
can't eat
um and the chocolate is uh
there's like dark chocolate and then
there's coconut like dark chocolate
that's like low calorie like zero
calorie you can eat that that's fine but
just eat them in their squares though
eat them in their squares you don't eat
the whole bar yeah eat like a square at
a time don't eat the whole thing uh tom
brady does that tom brady does that he
does it every now and then
and um
dark chocolate okay
speaking about chips real quick so i
mean i gotta ask that you're in britain
you've ever had some fish and chips
there
no
not really no
i know i genuinely i spent like all the
money i have to get here so i've been
eating in my apartment like the entire
time i and i know like people will say
like your parents are rich or whatever
but like
no ramen noodles yeah
raj no no i've just been waiting i've
been getting the big bags of rice and
like just eating like rice and like
chicken and ice cream i'm not gonna lie
i thought
you're eating like a buddhist man yeah
some of your teammates would be like
yeah i'm going to go to like weather
spoons you know after blah blah blah you
know get a pint
so
oh i don't i actually i haven't drank in
like two i'm trying to see how long i
can go without drinking i've never
drinking too much i'm about a year i
kind of can't do it anymore so i haven't
i haven't touched alcohol in five years
i'm five years sober
yeah
it's it's crazy for me because like i
like basically ever since i had my shirt
i'm like yeah i'm not doing it anymore
and all my friends look at me like
why do you have a reason to live and
it's like i actually used to be like
pretty big into beer but i was like uh
you know have my fun so
i just i just realized like i was gonna
get fat if i kept drinking i got
calculated the amount of calories it
would be in a year and i was like that's
like 10 to 20 pounds a year if you've
like a couple drinks a week
and i was like i'm gonna just cut it i
don't like it enough
the only time i really have anything
alcoholic is like when like the very few
times i'm cooking like a steak for me
i'll use like i'll use like red wine to
deglaze the pan and that's like that's
uh but i'm that's all the alcohol is
boiled off at that point when i'm making
a pan sauce so
i don't know it's it's it's definitely
interesting like just having my whole
experience i just feel like an old man
in a lot of ways but like everyone
around me is still like very much in
that college world so it's like uh you
know just kind of let everyone have
their fun you know it's not for me
anymore but that's fine so hey pearl um
since you like sports do you like to
work out because there are people who
play sports but they don't like to work
out
oh i like that's me
that's cool that's fine but just as long
as you eat healthy that's what matters
yeah no i like to lift so i can like
like i was doing um what was i doing
today like
260 for five today from like squats
so i could have
some strong legs
a while but in college i almost i was
like 10 i was 285 or 290 for a deadlift
so like i'm like pretty strong i love
lifting but i don't i'm not a big fan of
cardio i could like go without oh yeah
well so here's the thing here's the
thing that will make sure this can
transform anyone's body regardless of
how fat or skinny you are
if you mix your workouts because there's
body weight which is calisthenics and
then there's
there's olympic lifting there's power
lifting there's strength there's hit
which is high interval intense training
there's circuit training so all these
different training work even there's
even pull workouts i love doing pool
workouts as well you know one of my
favorite fighters george st pierre he's
been posting a lot of pool workouts and
i've been doing this years ago before he
did
and so pull workouts help a lot with
your ligaments with if you have injuries
um to getting into shape you actually
burn a lot sometimes more in the pool
workouts than you would do on a
treadmill or an elliptical
yeah
swimming is [ __ ] hard no no no but
you can you can sprint in the pool you
can do like sprint oh yeah okay yeah and
then you can do the elastic band you can
do the yeah you can do the water weights
the water weights in there or you can do
some lighter weights and bring the
lighter weight dumbbells into the pool
i've done that
and then um you do for about 45 minutes
to an hour but
you just have to have short breaks you
can't have long breaks because longer
breaks makes you more
lazier more steady
and you want to bring up the intensity
of your heart rate
and then on top of that you run like you
run uphill you do hiking you do
different things so you never want to
stay consistently comfortable with one
type of workout that's the trick to it
to transforming your body and getting
shredded or in shape or just leaner
that's the best thing because if your
body stays in a flux in a constant
relative flux that's what they say
um it stays steady it stays
docile
so it keeps you steady and kind of
comfortable so you're gonna settle and
then next thing you know you're gonna
get used to working out this way that
your body's never gonna know what's this
type of workout what's that type of
workout for example if you just stick to
body weight but then you start doing
like barbell weights that's different
your body's gonna feel it
so that's what you have to do so i would
do like every couple weeks
change it up so if like for two weeks
just do body weights but then do some
sprints
and then eat healthy and then rest and
then get you on your morning run
and then next thing you know you do your
pool workout on a couple weeks after
that and do some with the bars and then
just keep doing it and keep hitting your
abs
your stomach will go down because you're
saying you're trying to lose 20 pounds
in your belly or something that's what
you said
yeah well i just i've been the same
weight for like four years and i'm just
trying to get down to like like 20
pounds lighter because then i like i'm
in the right bmi that
okay so um there's there's two things
that i forgot to mention to you guys
listening um so people mess this up and
they do dynamic stretching with
aesthetic stretching
so
dynamic is warming up aesthetic is
cooling down
um
and so people come
what's the word they conflate both of
each other and they start doing cooling
down warm-ups
to cool down to start their workout but
then they feel lazy in their workout so
you never want to do that you want to do
dynamic stretching first
and then after you're done with your
workout when you're done then you do
aesthetic
stretching or aesthetic cooldowns
because what you want to do is you want
to hype and pump up your blood your body
when you're going to work out and start
it off you do about seven minutes to
eight minutes of
dynamic stretching and once you're done
you do about six seven minutes of
aesthetic cooldowns
so you know like the stuff where you
stretch your arms and you're sitting on
your butt stretching your legs that's
more cool down
jumping jacks and like
leapfrog like jump frogs or whatever
like stuff like that those are warm-ups
so you want to do those kind of things
and like uh high knees and stuff running
high knees those are all warm
that's what we do like for our team like
we'll usually do like that like that's
what we do
yeah because they want to cause it
because because they need to pump you
guys up before you start your practice
so you got to make sure there's not
pulling you down before you start your
practice does that make no sense you'd
be all lazy
you wouldn't want to do anything
are you sure
[Music]
um well i'm actually gonna go to bed
guys it's like
yeah it must be like my dog is like
crazy um
but yeah i'm gonna go to bed but thanks
for coming on the stream
it must be like like six 6 30 in the
morning over there or something like
that yeah i've had like a weird sleep
schedule here are you are you still like
are you still like kind of on that
central time
no i go i go to bed at like six or seven
in the morning here because my stuff is
at night and i think it's better to
stream on like u.s time so i just like
do it that way
but
when's your next stream yard gonna be
oh god i don't know um this was kind of
this is my first one i did like a
call-in
um probably what's today's sunday um
probably tuesday
yeah i'm in california right now so it's
like 9 30 at night
damn it
it's 5 a.m your time thanks for a great
job thank you for the donation i
appreciate all of them i'm like super
broke now so i appreciate it thank you
so much for coming on guys i'm going to
end the broadcast that's cool uh
talking to everyone um yeah
we're live all right mac mac do you have
uh instagram or do you have social media
oh man i'm basically a ghost right now
i'm sorry bro
i'll oh
yeah
like not to self advertise but i'm
thinking about creating like a
small little channel here when i just
talk about whatever pops in my mind
because
uh surprising to a lot of people
actually have something going on up here
so yeah
um